hello everybody hello hello if i sound um sick to you guys
right now it's because i am the prophecy has been foretold
from the dragoon that came by two days ago they it's like
they're they're like an oracle or some shit they're like i
won't see you tomorrow and i'm like what do you mean won't
see me tomorrow i'm gonna be streaming tomorrow and it
happened we have to burn that dragon he's a fucking witch
witch burn him anyway i might get light lightheaded if i
yell too much um it was foretold oh my god the great sage
that predicted the illness um anyway so i'm sorry toky thank
you um so i am sick today um i've been like ingesting
medication and sleeping and hydrating the last uh two days
basically you know in the morning on what day is it today
but i even i told you it on tuesday on on a tuesday i
started to stream i was like guys i think i'm gonna get sick
i'm getting sick right now i feel the sore throat and then
as the hours passed by it progressed so fast.
Usually it would take like a day until I actually get sick,
sick.
But literally by the end of the day, I, it was, I got a
fever.
By the end of the day, I was like, it's so cold.
Why is it so cold?
I was like, how do I'm in my blankets?
And I looked at it, but I was like, oh my God, it's at like
30 degrees.
I'm like, like my heater.
And I'm like, why is it so cold?
over it's fucking over um so yeah tuesday i hit my fever and
i think i like sweated it out by yesterday by wednesday um i
had to cancel god of war i know god of war is fucking cursed
as hell i was so sad um because i was actually really
looking forward to starting god of war ragnarok um yesterday
but like i was so out of it like i'm out of it now today as
well but i'm like I'm doing fucking Buzzfeed questions like
I'm doing Buzzfeed quizzes like that does not it does not
require a lot of brain power to write Buzzfeed quizzes so
I'm pretty sure it doesn't take a lot to fucking answer
Buzzfeed quizzes so I'm like that's fine I can stream this
um but like you guys might be like oh you sound you don't
sound too good yesterday was so fucking bad like I was
literally like barely conscious I think that's the worst
part the worst part is like I still had sick because I
couldn't get a dog sitter um this last minute like you know
that because like you know it's like I'm like I'm sick right
now and then like my usual dog sitter um wasn't free so I
was like okay I got tough in this outside so I had to like
walk him and feed him and like you know do all that shit um
um while I was like barely alive I was literally I walked
fed him and yeah I mean he doesn't even have to pay red the
least he could do is take care of me when i'm sick um anyway
so uh basically every like when i walk him and fed him i
literally just passed out uh uh i passed out like right
after and all i did was just sleep uh hydrate and then poop
because i don't know i was so happy when i was pooping um i
was like thank god because that means you're flushing for
those who don't know the reason that it's good when you're
when you're pooping a lot when you're sick because you're
flushing out all the bacteria out that's like causing like
your sickness so now I was like oh my god thank fucking god
that means I'm like you know I'm like flushing it out faster
too so I'm like please let it keep happening so I can flush
it out faster a little TMI a little TMI but it's a good
thing when you're pooping if you're sick Because that means
your body is getting rid of all the bacteria in your body.
Like actually getting it out of your system.
Gus, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Tomorrow's stream starts when I have classes.
So good luck on the ranker grind.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Richter, thank you.
The all-caps read before you even realized something was
wrong.
Thank you for the super chat.
Yeah, it's literally the great purge.
um yeah so i was very happy that um you know i was flushing
like my my my immune system was working uh because you don't
want to be constipated when uh when you're sick because
that's not good that means you're keeping the sickness
inside of you and that's not good for your that's not good
for for your fucking body who told you this lie google
google so i trust everything google tells me that's I live
my life um what else uh but yeah no yesterday um I was gonna
tell my uh because usually like when uh my manager doesn't
see me upload my waiting room overnight he makes it for me
uh uh so like but then he I literally I would clocked out or
I was started like having a fever I clocked out and just
like was just passed out in the bed and then my manager
usually when he doesn't see me upload a waiting room um um
over night he uploads it for me because he's eu so like his
morning is my night so he doesn't know i got like really
really sick like he's like oh maybe it's fine and i woke up
and i was like i'm not okay i was like i don't know if i can
do it i was like i think i think i could do like two hours
but that i'm i'm not okay i thought he's like yeah I know
don't stream.
I was like, you're right.
And then I passed out again.
And I passed out again.
I woke up and he was like, you gotta tell them that you're
not streaming because the waiting room is still up.
And I was like, oh yeah.
Okay.
Let me write, write this real quick.
And that passed out again.
And thank God I did not stream yesterday because I was
absolutely like fucked up.
I couldn't like, you know, like today I woke up and I could
breathe through my nose.
But everything my sinuses were all clogged up and everything
yeah like yesterday my sinuses were all clogged up i
literally had to i think that's the worst part when you're
when you're sick is breathing through your mouth when you're
sleeping because you wake up with super fucking dry mouth
and i fucking hate that um i hate waking up with like super
dry mouth when you're sick too
but today like i said i'm fucking oh i should take my i
should i'm gonna take my medicine real quick.
I'm going to take my day quill.
Wait, did I take my day quill already?
Oh, fuck.
No, I didn't.
Okay.
I was like, did I ingest day quill?
I've lost count.
I know I did it.
So let me ingest some day quill real quick.
I'm going to take my meds and then you guys will disappear.
Hmm.
Okay.
Slide.
They give us super chat.
Thank you.
I guess we're all starting new year sick.
Yeah, hope you get better soon.
Don't you think it was a super chat thing you think I know
It's such a cruel joke, you know You're like I'm like don't
worry guys 20 26 is gonna go so well And I fucking get sick
immediately on the first week of 20 26 Oh, yeah, it's first
week was the second week the second yeah, no, it's
practically the first week of 20 26 I just got I got sick
right.
That's like I don't know.
It's like an opener.
I'm a little afraid now for the rest of the year.
Solid Snake, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You gotta shoot that dragon to absorb their HP, don't keep
it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I gotta piece my AI overlords.
Because you know how like Google uses AI now for like Google
searches?
They just do a summary of like the top results, but
sometimes it's not true.
I don't remember what it was, but I remember when they first
tested out uh when they first tested out the ai search
function for google and then it was like absolutely wrong of
what you're supposed to do um yeah apparently the summaries
are not accurate at all what was it what was the thing that
that went viral um that uh the ai summary thing when they
first popped up i forgot what it was but uh people were like
don't do this don't use the summary oh is it the the glue oh
oh yeah putting glue on your pizza is good as a good idea i
think i remember how they googled it too yeah they would
source it from like reddit or some uh gordon thank you for
the super chat thank you thank you uh hey dokey's my buddy
thunder where's birthday today can you send him a very
sickly happy birthday please add random coffee mess and
nasally sniffles for him oh what a freaking freak about okay
gordon thank you for the super chat that's a homie right
there um enabling his sick fantasies uh That's a bro.
Thank you for the super chat, Gorda.
Thank you, thank you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear thunder.
Okay, that was not, that was not on purpose.
Happy birthday to you.
Yeah, happy birthday.
Yeah.
Okay, you know what?
up here i'll give you a sneeze too i'll get not sneeze i'll
give you a nose blowing too for free oh yeah so hot
um what else i say oh yeah very important announcement today
that i have to make uh because i wasn't able to make it
yesterday um um there's something i've been like looking
forward to talking about talking about for a very long time
so i'm fucking I'm so excited to I sad I wasn't able to
announce it yesterday because I was sick So I'm really happy
to be able to announce it today since like, you know, I
toughed it out And I was like, I'm gonna stream today.
I have to stream today.
Anyway Fortnite announced the self park collab guys.
Oh my god Self park is now on Fortnite.
Let's fucking go
One day you guys are gonna think it's a fortnight update
like I'll be like guys Guys, I have a very important
announcement today.
And then you guys all be like, oh, it's Fortnite, isn't it,
Doki?
And it's an actual real announcement.
It's like the boy who cried Fortnite.
Like, the boy who cried announcement.
I thought it was important.
Do you know how long?
Do you know how long I have been waiting for a Fortnite
collab with fucking South Park?
You guys know how ever since they announced, like, guys
simpsons uh bob's burger this is the one collab i've been
waiting for so long and it's it's finally here it's
self-park i don't think it was super chat thinking thank you
today is also my birthday can i have a clean happy birthday
of course you can uh also the repo guys are back in the
fortnite store too guys also that i have to buy anyway i
have code dokeybird please make sure to use the code don't
keep hurt for the South Park collab.
Oh, happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear.
Uh-huh.
Happy birthday to you.
Yeah!
Happy birthday!
Um, but yeah, I also wanted to, there's a lot of January
babies.
Yes, because July 4th, guys.
A lot of them, a lot of, a lot of their parents had a great,
uh, independence day.
Wait, what's the new?
Sorry, that's six months.
Wait, what, how many, how many, it's Halloween?
Did they have a good Halloween?
Wait, celebrating with, sorry, that's, that's, um, uh, six
months, sorry.
Um, I need, I can't count back.
Which month is it?
July is, okay, wait, which, that, which month is it?
Even less, yeah.
Oh, Easter, that's right.
In the name of, they had they had oh it's either or I mean
it was a late baby then spring break or April oh maybe April
fools you're pregnant April fools you're gonna be a dad whoa
you're like oh that's really funny it's like no it's for
real you're gonna be a dad please understand I'm sick guys
please understand I'm sick right now what else that was oh
yes uh and i think the funniest about the self-park collab
um is that is that tally is also in the game right now like
but like the but i i you know how like fortnite is still
like a kids game the fact that tally you know the guy that
does all sorts of of drugs and it's always high 24 7 it's
now it's now a sidekick uh so yeah the the the drugged up
towel is now a item in fortnite and also i the i for me the
funniest is this um is the cred backpack because i i'm
pretty sure ksi and jake i was a was a logan paul have been
trying to get like cosmetic, like Prime in Fortnite for a
long time.
And in the fact that CRED, the parody of Prime is, it's a
real, it's going to be a real item in Fortnite over Prime.
So I thought that was fucking hilarious because it's like,
oh my God, guys, we're finally going to get CRED, guys.
It's finally going to happen.
I can get cred.
Yeah, we can get cred, guys.
He's all about cred now.
Yeah, give me the cred.
So I like that, which means I feel like that means that
we're never going to get Prime in Fortnite.
Thank God.
Because like, I feel like Prime isn't even a thing anymore,
to be fair.
Like, I think the kids have moved on from Prime.
It's all about the six sevens now.
So I never even tried Prime.
I'm pretty sure.
I'm pretty sure it's like just a lot of fucking sugar.
and everything.
Yeah, I think like all the children have moved on from Prime
now.
Another very important announcement that I wanted to make,
that I couldn't make yesterday.
That's unrelated to Fortnite, which is an actual real
announcement.
I know I baited you guys with the Fortnite run.
Now I'm giving you guys a real announcement.
But I wanted to announce this yesterday as well.
But like I said, I was six, so I couldn't, you know, I
couldn't really stream yesterday.
But finally, Minecraft has a new update!
Oh my God!
So Minecraft, this just did, I'm like a fucking news VTuber
now too, like giving you all the hip, I'm literally BuzzFeed
the VTuber.
You wouldn't believe what they added in Minecraft, and it's
like a slideshow of all the baby Minecraft animals.
Hey, at least I didn't give you a slideshow, guys.
I didn't give you the slideshow.
I'm giving you the entire image right now.
um yeah i'm buzzbird um i'm your newest i'm your newest news
i'm your news source for all the all the trending topics um
you would not believe your eyes at what minecraft just added
yesterday um so minecraft did a huge update yesterday uh
where basically all the baby uh uh minecraft pets or animals
have like all that are now actual babies but say this might
be this might be like a controversial take i do not like the
sheep cow or pig baby baby minecraft uh change because i i
really i think those three were a downgrade for me
personally because i really like the giant ass heads i think
it's so fucking silly and i really like the the giant heads
that they have um but like the others it's because the cat
and the okay the cats have like giant heads so like that
makes sense like you know so i was like wondering why the
pigs or the the cows or the sheep have big ass heads i just
think that i just think that it was because like they're
like oh we want to make them look more like babies but the
cows look just like they just look like miniature cows they
don't look like baby cows to me the new cows literally just
cows.
They don't look like the baby cows.
The others look like babies, but the pigs and the cows don't
look like baby cows or pigs.
also, I love the chicken update for, uh, yeah, they just
look like short cows, like really tiny miniature, like
miniature pigs, you know, which are not real.
Apparently, by the way, miniature pigs aren't real.
I know, teacup pigs I think they're called teacup pigs.
It was a lie created by TikTok influencers.
Because, like, basically, whenever they get bigger, they
just, I guess they, like, just throw them away.
They just adopt a pig away and then just get a new baby pig.
Because teacup pigs are literally just regular pigs.
So they're not, they're like, look at my tiny teacup pig
that I got.
But they were just regular pigs that they just bought and
lied to us about how they were tiny, tiny pet-sized pigs.
Anyway, but yeah, no, the cows just look like miniature
cows, but is they real?
Anyway, so what I love about the new Minecraft update is the
things people were doing with the chickens.
Because they, okay, it was like all over my Twitter feed.
I think it was the Japanese minecrafters.
They're wild.
But basically, a Japanese minecrafter made a popcorn machine
with the baby chicken.
They're like, popcorn.
It's so fucking good.
And then, okay, the really messed up one.
I will say, there was a really messed up one.
right after popcorn and it was that a Japanese minecrafter
recreated the chicken factory with the chicks so he made a
sorting machine being like if it's a male chick we sort him
into the lava pen if it's a female chick we put him into the
pen and i'm like oh my god i was just like from popcorn to
like chicken factory that's abs that's like insane it's the
circle of life it's like whoa steve got a job at the chicken
factory
someone's gotta monitor this man like that is like the first
idea you had um when with the new update someone's gotta
monitor him i i'm scared anyway is that all the updates i
want to tell you guys today all the announcements but i
swear to god god of war is so fucking cursed every time
something happens when i want to stream god of war something
fucking happens to me it's like it's a pattern at this point
like once or twice it's like a coincidence three four five,
six, there's something going on with God of War.
There's something like someone out there does not want me to
stream God of War.
Anyway, like I said, even though I'm sick, I still want to
stream today because I felt like I said, like we're just
doing BuzzFeed quizzes and like BuzzFeed quizzes, you know,
like they don't put a lot of effort making these quizzes.
So I don't need to put a lot of effort answering the quiz.
I don't need to use a lot of my brain power to really answer
chilling it's like it's like the lockdown came back again
everyone's just fucking um answering random ass bus v
quizzes just past the time that's literally what it is right
now um so we're gonna be chilling um for those who never
experience bus v quizzes it is a an experience so i have no
idea why taylor swift has her own fucking category but like
i i guess you go you go girl uh i guess on BuzzFeed are
like, I don't know, Swifties.
Captain Apeball, they give a super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I know you're not streamed to them.
I just want you to know that you were my, were.
Wait, what happened to me?
What's going to happen to me?
But thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
So for those who never grew up with BuzzFeed quizzes,
BuzzFeed used to be incredibly popular back in the day.
um not just for quizzes but like did you know uh I have but
they did college college dropout right was was no not
BuzzFeed um BuzzFeed unsolved like mysteries and stuff like
that um BuzzFeed came from BuzzFeed because like you guys
like you know it's BuzzFeed and BuzzFeed had a lot of um a
lot of like fun activities back then uh yeah dropout is
college humor I was like I uh I always BuzzFeed sometime.
And you will be remembered.
Try guys.
Yeah, the try guys before the guy cheated on his wife used
to be from BuzzFeed as well.
They had a lot of really good YouTube channels, as well as
comics back then and animated series before they got like
way too big.
I think that's way too MCM-like, and then they got too big
to cut.
It's like the Roman Empire.
I know, I always think about the Roman Empire.
You know, like they conquered everything, and then they
conquered like so many land, but it got too big that all the
land started falling apart.
So it's literally, the BuzzFeed was like the Roman Empire.
They tried to pursue endless growth, and then everything
just came crashing down in the end because it was just too
many people, too many BuzzFeed channels.
uh to not really no it's true they had the thing is they had
a lot of like million like million plus subscriber channels
um and um and they had like a lot of like animation shorts
animations to channels too and i used to watch this and like
animation channel from buzzfeed the creator left uh because
the creator from for one of them was like one of my favorite
artists um and uh or like to Roman BuzzFeed.
Yeah, and they want to both serve for journalism too.
And yeah, so they had a lot, but then it ended up crashing
down, but at least we still have their BuzzFeed quizzes.
Their BuzzFeed quizzes were notorious for being so fucking
random.
Like, I will show you what I mean.
I can tell when you meet your soulmate based on the rom-com
you watch.
uh uh let's see this which one is it we dare you to choose
the ultimate respond to these texts from your ex and we'll
tell you what your biggest relationship strength is which
josh hutcherson character would make for your perfect
boyfriend uh like it's just so fucking random watch some 90
movie movies and we'll guess your favorite ice cream flavor
uh plan a 2020s marathon and we'll guess your birth month so
it's like it's like all like it's it's just all fucking like
how do you fucking figure this out but apparently it does it
reveals your deepest darkest secrets about you um anyway
we're gonna uh some of you guys have suggested some quizzes
so um we're gonna do some right now i don't know i'm gonna
pick randomly from all the tabs i've opened and also maybe
after all the quizzes you guys suggest we'll also look at
the other other quizzes we can find all right Fill your play
with cartoon foods and I should that sound I want.
Okay, here you go.
All right, build a transformer and we'll tell you if you're
an Autobot or a Decepticon.
All right, oh my gosh, that's so easy.
Okay, never mind.
All right, what state do you actually belong?
Okay, I'm going to do this one first.
Guys, sorry, I have to like skip.
I actually, I want to find a really good, juicy one to start
with.
Since I am Canadian, I figured this one will be funny.
Because I want to know, like, what state do I belong in if I
was American?
Um, yes, very random.
Which of these is your favorite fast food chain?
I, okay.
What's the fuck or half of these?
Like, the difference that the Roman Empire was still
interesting after its fall.
Papa, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay.
I have never, okay.
I don't know what to say.
borrowers jerry's givers what a burger papa okay space
aliens okay that has to be like area 51 or some shit
wherever that's that's from that's like where is area 51
again i know chick-fil-a i know chick-fil-a dunkin donuts i
like dunk-in donuts um in asia what the fuck pt the game
taco johns chinos what okay nevada that has to be a nevada
thing space aliens and moxie okay the only one i actually
know is chick-fil-a and dunkin donuts but i've never had
chick-fil-a before i just know about them um because
apparently their chicken is really good um and the only
place i've actually ever been to any of these was dunkin
donuts not even pop eyes no i don't think we have pop eyes
in canada or maybe we do maybe it's like one restaurant
Dunkin' Donuts is mid in NA.
I will say that.
I'll do Chick-fil-A just because, like, everyone says
Chick-fil-A is really good.
So I'll go with Chick-fil-A.
I've never been to Chick-fil-A, but I'll go with
Chick-fil-A.
Which of these TV shows appeal to you the most?
Army Wives, Drew Carey, Breaking Bad Community.
Oh, shit.
Okay, I've actually been re-watching Community.
I think community writing is so good.
I will, like, I think, like, okay, the only issue is, like,
overall, though, community, season one to three are very
strong, and then after that, it's not so good.
Parks and Rec, season one fucking sucked, but after season
one, it's all good.
The office, it's good overall, but, like, I laughed more
watching community than I did.
like either Parks and Recs or the office because community
had like shock humor and I fucking love shock humor.
You can't be putting thought into this if you want the
genuine BuzzFeed experience.
I'm sorry, I'm sick right now.
So like my mind ain't going doing so well.
I think I'm going to say community because the writing, I
lack more in community Season 1 and 3 were so strong, and
it's, I laughed more in community than I ever did on Office
or Parks and Recs, so I'm gonna go with community.
Choose a baby, okay.
Okay, who, who, guys, which, okay, I like this baby.
Wait, but then it's Vincent Adult Man.
Okay, wait, this baby looks like he can pay my rent.
I'm gonna choose this baby.
Which animal do you...
Yeah, it's a boss, guys.
It's...
He looks like the boss.
Which animal do you feel best represents you?
Alright.
Okay, I mean, obviously...
Okay, there's a chicken.
And then there's a robin.
Oh my god, I forgot to tell you guys the story.
I was at a park.
I was, like, at a park that was, like, sort of, like, not
just a park part.
But, like, it's sort of, like, in the woods type deal.
a hawk started circling dad and I freaked the fuck out
because I was like, oh my, it's trying to kidnap my dog.
And it was literally, like, I saw the shadow of a hawk,
like, in like the shadow of it flying past.
And I was like, oh, it's a, that's a big ass bird.
And then it came back.
It came back and I was like, wait a minute.
And it started like circling him.
And I was like, oh my god and i like ran i was like come dad
get over here i don't you're gonna get fucking kidnapped
yeah that actually wasn't fucking i've never had that fear
before but now i have a new fear this is why i stay in the
city guys this is exactly why i stay in the city uh yeah i
was just like i was just like oh I googled it.
I was like kid hawks kidnap my dog and they're like Usually
a hawk wouldn't be able to carry Carry dog like dogs because
like they they usually hunt for like squirrels and stuff I
guess he thought my he thought my dog was a giant ass
squirrel But like at best it would just like they would try
to carry him But they might not be able to pick him up
because he's like 10 plus pounds I think they just thought
he was a fucking giant rat um or a giant squirrel because it
wasn't like a giant hawk it was like it was like a medium
size wait they can okay maybe i i don't want to test it you
he is like 15 plus pounds so like i was i'm just thinking
they're like usually they can't carry 10 plus pounds like oh
my god but thank god thank god you're thick dad thank
fucking god yeah but it's a talent so that like freaked me
the fuck out because i legitimately thought he was gonna he
was actually about to get kidnapped and then i ran out there
it's like get away and he's safe now this is why i was like
i'm trying to a new dog park because i was like oh it's like
sort of in the woods and stuff so it's like more naturey and
yeah i went to a went to an actual naturey park once and a
hog tried to kidnap him um jacardo thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you went to a park once and immediately
try to kidnap Zach potentially and gives Doki a reason not
to go outside or to a park again.
They give him the super chat.
They can think.
And he wasn't aware.
The thing is, he didn't even know it was happening.
He was like mid, the fucking scariest part was that when the
hawk was circling him, he was mid poop.
So, so he's just, it was giving me eye contact too.
I don't know if your dog does that, but do your dogs, do
your, oh yeah, There's no BGM.
I forgot I put DGM, but your dogs look give you eye contact
when they poop because my dog does that He was giving me eye
contact while a hawk was circling him and I was like, oh my
god, bro like please, please for the love of God All right,
let me find let me okay here I'll give you guys music Yeah,
I was just like no fucking survival instinct at all.
Yeah, his guard was down.
He was, how dare he try to hunt him when he's pooping.
I heard, I read about that.
Like, if a cat if a cat like poops in front of you, was it
cats?
I think it was like, if a cat poops or pees in front of you,
he trusts you to like, he trusts you because you're like,
you know, it's like his most vulnerable state.
So if they're willing to do it in front of you, that means
he fucking you to not hurt him little fun fact anyway oh
there's a roadrunner oh my god there's a fucking swan what
am i a chicken a robin a roadrunner no i don't i fucking
hate running though guys i'm a roadrunner i guess it looks
most like a chocobo too
but you guys are more like a chicken though you guys are a
chicken Not me.
I feel like, okay, I'll do Roadrunner.
What quality are you most attracted to?
Mysterious.
I just want them to be nice to me.
That's a lot.
Unpredictable seems too much.
That explains your kitty motto, Gavin.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I just want them to be nice to me.
That's all.
Which one of these negative adjectives best applies to you?
Uh...
Okay.
Cold.
I do have a cold right now.
I...
I'll be like, no.
This is 2026.
There's no...
There's still plenty of year left, Toki.
We still have the rest of 2026 left before you get there.
Wait, is it distracted?
Distracted.
Yeah, I didn't even see that.
I got distracted.
I got so distracted.
I didn't even see distracted.
Pick a musician.
That's Elvis.
Oh, that's the girl that sang Valerie.
I don't know half.
Oh, that's Bob Marley.
I don't know half of these.
The only one I recognize is Elvis personally.
I don't know who these other people are.
I'm sorry.
I know their voice is, but like, I'll pick Elvis Presley
because I know who Elvis is.
Which of these names will you choose for your baby?
Alexander?
That's such an old man's name.
I'm sorry to all the Alexander's.
I mean, like, Alex seems fine, but Alexander seems like such
an old man name.
Okay, same with Abigail.
I'm sorry, your name Abigail.
Is that not Bob Marley?
Who's this guy?
I feel like Michael is like the safest name out there.
Which of these is your favorite movie quote?
Oh, who's Jimmy Hendrix?
Sorry, I don't know who Jimmy Hendrix is.
I don't know who Jimmy Hendrix is, guys.
I'm sorry.
Which of these is your favorite movie quotes?
I'm, uh, I guess I'm just not that old.
I told you guys, all the music I discovered, because, like,
I was so not, like, I was so sheltered that I don't know,
like, a lot of music back then, because all I did was just
listen to, um, shut up.
I all I did was just listen to Disney songs and then when
people ask me what my favorite song is I didn't want people
to think I was a kid so I'll be like Britney Spears and
they'll be like what song from Britney Spears do you like
and I'll be like oh I like all of them but I've never
listened to Britney Spears I just know she was super popular
back then and then later on Glee came out and that's when I
discovered other types of music existed other than Disney
and I just like, oh, that's Amy.
Oh, Amy Winehouse.
Oh, not Amy Winehouse.
No, that's, no, not Amy Winehouse.
Um, Amy Winehouse is, sorry, that's not her.
Um, that's, I was like, oh, Amy Winehouse sang Valerie.
I don't know who she is.
I just realized I actually don't know who this person is.
Uh, so what do you listen to now?
Um, Nintendo Coffee Shop Instrumentals.
That's what I'm working.
What I listen to now.
I just don't have time to listen to music.
Because I'm always working.
The full circle.
Like the...
I don't like listen to music.
I don't like to listen to music when there's lyrics playing.
Just because I can't focus at all.
Because like when I'm typing messages and stuff.
It's like...
When I'm typing messages.
and I'm listening to music with lyrics in there.
Like, my head would focus on the lyrics and I just fuck up
whatever I'm typing.
That's why I just listen to instrumental.
I'm firmly believing the philosopher rule in class,
especially since I rule.
I like that.
Oh, man.
How do you get the beans above the Frank?
I gave Jesus a chance, but it just didn't work out between
us.
We are the titans, the mighty, mighty titans.
there's no goonies never say that gooners never say that i
mean it works both ways um all i need are some tasty way
with waves a cold bus and i'm fine going to get 4.0 in
damage doing stuff is over okay okay okay uh we are on a
mission from god you got rvs all over me say hello to my
little No place like home.
Okay, actually.
Gooners never die.
Never say die.
That's a fucking crazy lie.
Yeah, I was like, what?
Choose an actor.
I don't.
Oh, okay, bitch.
Um.
I, okay.
I don't know.
I will say I was actually going through men in black
nostalgia.
recently.
It's hard.
I was going through men in black nostalgia, like, literally,
like, an hour ago, too.
But, like, I don't know.
I was going to say either Aaron Paul or is Ellen an actor?
Yes, she played Dory.
She was literally Dory in Finding Mimo.
I look, I know a lot of people forgot about it, but, like,
she, she, before she was a talk show host um she was
actually a very well-known actress and she was also dorian
finding memo yeah she had her own tv show before then and
now she lives in the uk i guess like uh because she got
exposed her being not a very nice lady
oh my god i'm gonna say will smith just because i was going
through i was watching men and Black clips recently, like
literally an hour ago.
I want to do a watch along for Men in Black because I never
watched the third movie and I want to do like a marathon for
memory stream.
Um, I really want to do a watch a lot of Men in Black
because I fucking love Men in Black and I, but I got like
super nostalgic over like, I wish they, I wish like, okay,
you guys would be like, but they did rebuke the snow.
We do not count the fucking Chris Hemmsworth version of Men
in Black International, whatever the fuck that was.
I didn't watch Men in Black for them, but like i heard it
was really fucking bad and i i denounced it as part of the
men in black franchise it does not count um but uh i love
men in black and i really i miss i really love the animated
shows too i used to watch that shit all the time we need men
in black for like actual men in black for it yeah they made
a men in black for and it was like called men in black
international but it's not it started like none of the none
of the actual none of the actors from Men in Black.
Other than the Pug, apparently.
The Pug King back.
Let's see.
Brickilicious.
Ha ha ha!
Cotton eye jump!
Shots, shot!
Okay, cotton eye jump!
Yeah, there's a Men in Black animation.
It's really fucking good.
I highly recommend it.
okay that that's i do not where is the city i don't which of
these pictures is most appealing to you this is where where
dad will get kidnapped this they already have a fucking hawk
ready to kidnap my dog um
one looks miserable because I feel like the HOA would be
would be here.
The hawk can't hurt you anymore.
The least amount of grass please.
Okay I do not like any of these places.
Like all these places fucking suck.
I want a fucking city.
Oh my god this is actually the only the only thing I can
select to.
Link removed at the owner's request.
Where can okay, this is the only place where I can get
Wi-Fi, but it also looks like one of the most miserable
places.
One of the Windows background.
This looks like a Windows.
This looks like, okay, I'm going to grab this one.
This looks like a Windows background right there.
The OG Windows background.
Also, I don't know what it looks like when I press the last
one, so I'm just going to double check.
Where the fuck is this place?
all right so i would most likely be in colorado uh where the
fuck is color what is colorado don't for you are a reliable
person someone friends and family can count on yay you're
constantly there for those oh look at that guys oh wait i'm
from soapbox let's go it was meant to be i was meant to be a
soapbox character
you're the kind of person when people talk about say and say
i love that dude people also say you could probably beat
them in a foot race often too trust me oh my god guys look
at that if i was american i'd be in fortnite right now i'll
be in colorado look at that manifest destiny look at that
i'm a colorado girl if i wasn't canadian all right next quiz
all right let's all right what is your inner okay let's do
what is this all right here go 99 of americans know so
little about canada that they can't even get two questions
right on the super easy canadian history quiz all right
let's see as a fellow coloradian let's see if i can figure
this out yep i'm from the great white north though be a
toronto girl okay this is just All right, what is Canada's
cap?
Um, that's, um, watching Doki Live from Colorado right now,
W.
Colorado, A-A-D.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Well, that's me, Toronto, right?
Toronto seems like a lot, or was it, I don't, I don't, never
hear anything about Ottawa, but I know Ottawa is important.
I'm going to say Ottawa.
Oh, I'm correct.
Yes, I fucking knew.
Okay, yeah.
Yeah, I know Toronto is, like, the biggest city.
But I always hear a lot about Ottawa.
But I'm like, what the fuck does Ottawa give us?
And then Ottawa is where the capital city is.
Although Toronto is Canada's biggest city.
Ottawa is the country's capital and home of Ireland.
Yeah, there you go.
Here you go.
What is Canada's tallest structure?
Oh, that's...
What the fuck?
Why would I need to know this as a fucking Canadian?
We don't fucking care what's tall.
The CN Tower?
Yeah!
At 553 meters, the CN Tower surpasses all of the structures
in Canada.
Who was Canada's first... Okay, I definitely know it's not
Stephen...
Oh, John Ab... Okay, it's John A.
McDonald.
Who the fuck is John Ab?
Okay, there's three Johns.
John's as Prime Minister.
I can't keep track of all of them.
You know, deep down in your heart, I'm actually from
Colorado.
Don't keep, please.
Look, we had lots, I know it's not Stephen Harper, because
that's the guy from before Trudeau.
That's crazy that Justin Trudeau is now dating Katie Perry,
by the way.
Bro, okay, someone, I saw a tweet that was like, has the
most generational run ever and it's like because like before
he was our prime minister um he the very first job he did
was a skateboard instructor then a fucking uh middle school
teacher and then a fucking um a talk show host and then he
became prime minister of canada where he destroyed our
economy and then and now he's dating katie berry now he's
now he's just Katie Perry's girlfriend.
The boyfriend, sorry, Katie Perry's boyfriend.
What a fucking resume.
Oh yeah, and his favorite party trick, his favorite party
trick is that he would pretend he would fall down the stairs
and be okay.
Literally, there's an interview of him being like, what's
the favorite party trick that you would like to do?
And then he was like, oh, I love falling down the stairs and
making people freak out, and then, but I'll be fine.
And then, um, And then like, and also he did like a, before
he became Prime Minister, he did a, he did like a strip
tease for charity.
I think he was like still part of the party back then, but
it's like, oh, it's charity.
Why don't you strip for, there's videos of it.
And then there's videos of it.
And he literally like fucking danced on a pose and started
stripping for charity and a political, in a political.
dinner and like a political party dinner or some shit
there's videos of it i have watched the video because i was
like that's gonna be our prime minister
let's get it let's get it no it was not a box during i've
seen the video i remember watching that video because he got
became our prime minister and then like my friend showed me
the video and was like bro have you seen the video of him
fucking stripping i was like no and But he has the
post-generational run ever as a politician.
What is going on in Canada?
Congrats, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I thought I was like crazy.
Alright.
What's on the Canadian...
Okay, a maple leaf.
I know that.
Congrats, it's the maple leaf.
Yay!
I can't have it.
The fact that he became Katie Perry's boyfriend too.
Right after he stopped being the Prime Minister.
He was like, what should I do next?
Divorce my wife and start dating Katie Perry.
That's insane.
Wording greeners of poutine.
All right, fries, gravy, and cheese curds.
We all know that.
Gamers God, again, he's just doing fucking side quest.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, she divorced.
She divorced.
I didn't keep track on who divorced who.
I just know, like, I was like, what the fuck?
Like, they got divorced?
Um, okay.
That, I know.
I love Poutine.
Uh, Poutine is so fucking good.
What is this body?
What?
Oh, it's Hudson's Bay.
Yeah, that's the only, that's the only pool of water I know
in Canada.
I'm like, what the fuck is Moose Coast and McKenzie Trail.
I was like, Ontario has a fucking lake.
Bro, I don't know.
They don't fucking live in Ontario.
I know what Hudson Bay is.
Oh, because, yeah, I know what Hudson Bay is because I know
the department store.
That's why.
I was like, I didn't even know it was water.
I thought it was a department store.
I have, but we can't because it's got to be marketed.
Wait, kids, protein marketed as an exotic dish.
That's crazy.
It's literally fries, cheesecruits, and gravy.
And America fucking loves gravy.
What's on the Canadian dollar coin?
Oh, it's a loon.
That's right.
Our coins are animals.
That's why I always, it's funny when I tell people, it's
loonies and tunies.
People think I'm like making shit up when I'm like, oh,
yeah, the dollar is called loony.
And the two dollar coin is called tunie because it's two.
It's not because there's two birds.
It's just because it just sounds cuter.
Yeah, loonies and tunies.
That's why we call it loony.
The tunie has a polar bear.
It has nothing to do with a bird.
You could trace the card.
This isn't a real...
Yeah, see?
It's a loony.
There it is.
Our $2.
Our $2 coin has a polar bear.
Our $0.05...
Okay, 5...
Okay, it's crazy.
Our $0.05 is a beaver.
Our $0.20.
25 cents is a moose um and our and our 10 cents is a fucking
boat i don't know why like i don't know why why like we had
a good pattern going on we were like we were like fever
moose loon um um polar bear and then we ran out of animals i
guess so then we fucking put a boat on it.
Yeah, we put yeah, we ran out of fucking animals.
We're like, what else?
Well, the Canadian animals we have.
And we're like, I don't know, put a fucking boat on it.
Yeah, my favorite animal, a fucking boat.
The apex ready of the ocean.
The boat.
Exactly.
It's what the bullet band left behind.
The first animal.
A John ass boat.
all right what is not a canadian airline okay i thought west
jet was american for the longest time because that was like
the one you took to go to america because they're apparently
partnered with delta airlines so i always thought that west
jet was part of like america like i thought it was an
american airline because it was like the only airline that
flies to fucking america but i know that's canadian because
my friend was like, I was like, I was like, man, I hate
American Airlines, man, I hate WestJet.
And then my friend was like, WestJet is fucking Canadian.
What the fuck do you mean?
And I was like, oh, like, wait, what?
What do you mean?
I know it's not, I know it's not these two.
Air Canada fucking sucks too.
Um, I guess North Wing, I don't, I've never heard of Otter
these.
Oh, nice.
But North Wing sounds cute, right?
I don't know what the fuck is air trans at um when was
Canadian 1812 oh 1860 in 1812 we burned okay I thought okay
1812 was when we burned the White House down that's all I
could remember from the famous song do you guys know the
song the famous song I know it was in the 1800s um oh my god
is that the bite of 67 oh my god it is oh my god In 1812, we
were at war.
The War of 18...
Wait, I'll link it to you guys.
It's a really good song.
And we burn the White House, sir.
And the White House burn, burn, burn.
Please, if any FBI agents are watching me right now, it is a
joke.
I do not want...
Please, I'm not trying to commit a federal crime or inciting
any federal crime right now.
I'm just singing a really funny song.
um about 1812 where the canadians did burn the white house
down and it was a funny song i think it's this one let me
track okay i'm gonna make sure all right white house song
the war of 1812 no burn burn burn all right here we go all
right what's Wayne Gretzky's famous that's a hockey player
right I'm too proud Canadian right bottom of TV oh my god
nights in Canada there was no cbc
president was mad from the president you know the body tell
the british where did it have to go he thought he invade
canada he thought that he was tough sorry i'm just listening
to a song one to washington
And burn the white hounds Lighthouse Burn, burn, burn Burn,
burn Bam, bam, bam, bam Bam, bam, bam, bam Daimless is a
good song Miss Wenwen The War of 1812 That's how I know
about the war And also Italia too Okay Okay Winning isn't
everything, but wanting to win is.
Oh, you miss 100% of the shots you don't take.
Oh my God, wait, that came from Wayne Gretzky?
Oh my, I didn't even realize that was him.
I'm, wait, that, you miss 100% of the shots you don't take.
That's a good fucking quote.
And Wayne Gretzky, that's a good ass quote, bro.
Yeah, I did not know, she knows hockey.
That's right.
That's how you know I'm Canadian.
What's the longest street in Canada?
The fuck?
I don't know.
Road?
Oh, Yonge Street?
Might be a famous as downtown Toronto Main Street, but it
actually stretches.
Bro, I don't fucking know.
I don't know anything about Toronto.
What's the name?
That, what is that?
What the fuck is that?
What is the name of this Canadian?
This is why this state in Canada.
oh my god i don't even know what this is bro that's why i
didn't go went out of went beyond canada i don't know maple
charts oh butter charts and my uncle makes the best one
where who makes these i've never seen this before in my
fucking life what's lm mcgomery the author of oh add of
green gables i know that because they always force you to
read this book and then we're all so proud of this book um
although all those and all those are written by canadians oh
wait the handmaid's tale was canadian wait life of pie is
canadian wait a minute life of pie
is that book from india okay wait david What the fuck wrote
this book?
Wait, yeah.
Oh, those novels are written by...
I was gonna say...
Life of Pi is written by a Canadian?
I was like, but this thing is...
Oh, based off of Jan Martel.
He was born in Spain.
Oh, it's a Canadian author, okay?
I was like, bro, this man's born in Spain.
Yeah.
Yeah, okay.
He moved to Canada.
use canadian though that's crazy also i'm surprised the
handmaid's tale is is written by a canadian isn't that the
one where it's based in america where like women don't have
rights and then they flee to canada no yeah i was just gonna
say i was like i was like thinking like like the whole
premise is that like like america turned into this fucking
country where like like women are of all rights but it was
only in america like it's only it's only in america where
all of this happens so the rest of the countries are like
are like okay they're all just like watching the what the
fuck is going on in the states right now and because like
it's just all in fucking america and then like because like
in canada everything is normal and then the whole thing is
that I never watched it had me, so I did read a summary of
it.
Like, I read, like, summary of some of the episodes and
stuff.
And I've seen parodies of it.
And then, like, and then, like, to, like, free themselves,
like, the women, like, did, like, broke out.
It's, like, prison break.
But, like, the prison is America.
And then, like, they fucking ran in Canada.
And it's all fucking fine over there.
I don't swear, yeah, I read the Spartan.
So, I'm very surprised.
surprised that I thought this was written by an American
that's pretty funny I did not realize handmade so was
written by Canadian yeah because it because I remember that
people were like really mad about hands-made tales because I
read about it people were like oh wasn't because when the
show first came out everyone everyone was like talking about
it and everything and they're all like oh my god it's such a
good like when the show first came out everyone was like
talking about how like interesting it was and everything and
then I was like and then I realized I think kept making more
seasons about it and i was like bro what the fuck why
because like the women escaped america and then like went to
canada so i was like why would they need more seasons and
apparently she went back to america to start like a
revolution it's like prison it really basically was like
prison break where they broke out of prison but they had to
keep going because people love the show so they went back to
prison yeah and then they went back to prison to do what
Another prison break.
It's literally like that.
That was really funny.
Yeah, like in Lost.
Yeah, exactly.
Like, they're lost, but then they're not lost anymore.
So they go back to the island to be lost again.
Yeah, they're like, let's run it back.
What's your...
Oh, Terry Fox.
I know him.
Everyone always talks about him.
Basically, he's a famous run.
He's like a...
This guy had cancer, and that's why his leg is amputated.
So he's amputated, and then all he does, like, marathon runs
to raise money for cancer.
Yeah, the Terry Fox run is very famous.
He raised money for cancer research.
See, I'm so Canadian.
Bro, what the fuck is?
Who the fuck goes to National Park?
The first time, the first and last time I went to a national
park, my dog almost got kidnapped by...
a hawk.
I don't fucking do this.
I don't do nature.
That's crazy.
I live in Canada and I don't do nature.
I'm so Canadian.
I am the most city-like Canadian out there.
Look, there's different genres of Canadians, okay?
We have the nature Canadians and the city Canadians.
I'm the city Canadian.
I'm not here about the natures.
We don't do nature here.
Being born in Alberta.
I don't realize how awesome this gem was.
Alright.
Which Canadian director has... Oh, James Cameron.
Yeah, did you guys know James... Actually, he's the avatar,
bro.
Uh, wait, Tim Burton?
There's no way Tim Burton.
Wait, what?
Bro, all we... Bro, what the fuck?
There's no way.
Tim Burton.
He's Canadian?
No, yeah, he is an American.
Yeah, like, I was gonna say, there's no fucking way this guy
is Canadian.
I know James Cameron is Canadian.
Um...
another billion dollars yeah okay yeah i was gonna say
christopher nolan and um christopher nolan i was like i'm
pretty sure he's british uh no no no it's just these are all
like um bait none of these guys are Canadians i don't know
who david kronenberg is but i know james cameron i was like
i know james cameron um is canadian Did you know this guy is
an actual artist?
He created the design for Predator.
He created the mask design of Predator.
Like, he was an artist before he became a director.
And he also drew, he also created the design for the alien
queen.
He was a painter before he became a director.
Yeah.
wait i'll show you guys it was so interesting because i was
reading about it it was so funny he was like people were
like when are you gonna make avatar 4 and this he was like
during interviews like bro i just spent 10 years making
avatar 2 and 3 please relax like he's just he's like please
relax i'm so tired i'm so fucking tired i literally just
finished Like, film it, make you Avatar 4.
And, like, Avatar 3.
And you want Avatar 4.
Like...
I'll show you guys.
He also does that.
This is literally, like, his...
I'll show you guys his artwork.
He's a really talented artist.
He also created the...
He created the artwork for the Terminator movies, too.
Like, the original Terminator design.
Yeah, I'll show you his artwork.
Bro, how he came up with, like, the Avatar design, he was
like, it came to me in a dream.
He literally woke up and drew the fucking face of Avatar,
and he was like, I want to make a movie about her.
But this is literally, like, his artwork.
This, too.
He drew, he designed the, uh, he designed the alien queen
and everything.
And then this one is, yeah, the sketch on the right, This is
his sketch on the right.
And that's how he came up with Avatar.
He literally, like, had a dream about the Avatar women.
And he woke up and he's like, I must draw this.
He's like, I must draw this.
She was so beautiful.
And then he's like, I shall make a movie about this woman
now.
Like, it literally came to him in a dream.
He like woke up, drew this, and was like, this shall be my
next movie.
Bro had it.
I must make my dream waifu a reality.
Like, it probably came up early overnight.
Yeah.
It literally came to him in a dream.
No, that's his story.
That's what he said.
That was the very first sketch of the Avatar women of
Avatar.
except this original character do not steal bro what's the
right let him go
draw me like you're now the women oh yeah and then people
are like oh when would you go and become an american citizen
and he's like bro that's too much he's like i don't want to
be dual citizen i just want to chill He's like, I just want
one passport.
Lastly, what's the group of seven known for?
Oh, painting.
Yeah!
I scored better than 50%.
There you go.
What's that?
Let's go.
See, guys?
I fucking, I'm so Canadian, guys.
12 out of 17.
I'm a real Canadian.
Let's go.
I took the Canadian test.
Let's see.
Congrats.
Let's go.
I knew I am Canadian.
I am a Colorado Canadian right there.
All right, what's next?
All right, tell us about yourself and we'll reveal which
pizza topping you are.
I gotta keep my passport, I know.
All right, how many people are in your close friend group?
I don't want, okay, four, I guess like four.
Wait, three.
The sloppy sisters.
I don't know, I have more one-to-ones.
I have one-to-one friends.
like friend groups um i'll just do three just for sloppy
sisters which would describe you uh i'm happy okay that's is
either quiet or happy or outcast depending on the situation
i will say i'll say quiet it depends on situation well
people i don't think i didn't count myself i'll say quiet
which Regent West Coast, baby.
What's your favorite, Slytherin?
What's your favorite subject?
Surprisingly, it was science.
I'm a...
Oh my god, I refuse to be pineapple!
No!
You're sweet.
I refuse to be pineapple!
I'm retaking it.
Okay.
One, quiet, West Litterhead Science.
I'm still pineapple!
Okay, one, Elkast, West Litterhead Science.
Oh my God, no, I'm mushroom!
These are all shitty toppings.
Mine has a curse of pineapple for it to be a pineapple.
But okay, I'd rather be pineapple than mushroom.
even worse I have to be a mushroom that is worse than
pineapple my Italian bloodline just grimaced in pain from
your answer thank you for the super chat Gorda thank you
thank you pat your ass shoot thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you pineapple oh she got it then give the
super chat thank you thank you this is pineapple behavior
quiet thank you for the super chat thank you thank you i
can't believe i'm a pineapple i don't i can't even be
pepperoni i wanted to be pepperoni oh my god okay eat a five
course meal and i'll reveal which rodent you are all right
what kind of rodent will i be guys what the fuck would pick
carrot juice milk orange juice i would like orange juice.
I like orange juice.
Pick an appetizer.
Um, burnt, oh, uh, burnt weener.
It's a sausage.
Main course.
Who the fuck eats popcorn as a main dish?
Who the fuck would pick orange chicken?
Okay, I'll pick pizza.
I'm sorry.
Orange chicken isn't even like Chinese.
Like, it's not even a Chinese dish.
It was invented by Americans.
Like,
do all right I did but it's so good though okay but when you
have like other like Chinese chicken dishes you will not
think like orange chicken is like that good I personally am
I personally am not a fan of orange chicken I think it's way
too sweet Chinese Americans it's like fortune cookies we
don't who don't know uh fortune cookies are not even chinese
it's like invented by like in america
it's not even like like we don't have fortune cookies in
like at like actual china it was just like a little like oh
like i was like whoa pick a dessert cigarettes
Okay, I can't wait for my cigarette to end my meals.
The French option.
The cigarette tab.
I want to say, I'm going to say macaron.
I love macaron.
What am I?
I'm a hamster.
Yes, Lottie's not a fucking raccoon.
I'm fine with that.
You're a hamster.
and sometimes don't realize how much you love to hide and
dig around.
I like to hide in my own shit, I guess.
Like that sounds.
Yay.
Raptaro.
Na na na na na.
Na na.
Na.
What's the Ham-Taro?
That's the Ham-Taro ending theme, right?
The English one.
I gotta pull it up.
Now I'm curious.
Ham-Taro ending theme.
I love the English themes of Ham-Taro, too.
Ham-Taro English opening.
Is that the opening or the ending?
No, that has to be the ending.
Row.
And a- Bada-Bada-Bada-A-Ham-Taro.
What is it?
Let's go!
Yeah, it is!
Here you go.
The ending slapped too.
I like the Hamtaro ending, the English one.
It's a little quiet though.
Bro, the drummer was going at it.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah y'all a five where
are you what the fuck is this you're a five nights at
freddie's animatronic and how you play the game determines
which one okay sorry Let's see.
All right, let's see what five nights of Freddy's
animatronic I am.
All right, we're done.
It's time to find out which five nights of Freddy's
animatronic you're most likely based on how you play the
game.
Where are you most likely to hide in the FNAF 1 restaurant?
Um, I'll hide in the bathroom because everyone thinks you're
always safe in the bathroom.
So I'll hide in there.
So I'll get them when they're most vulnerable.
Just like how the hawk was trying to kill my, like get that
my dog.
Which strange addiction do you have?
Uh, social distancing.
That's okay.
Alright.
You get it, God.
You get it, yeah.
Um, which set of animatronics are your favorites?
Uh, I think the class.
I mean, okay.
I, okay, I'm gonna say the toys, because cheek is hot.
She gets hotter in the toys version.
Which game model is your favorite?
We're talking about the animatronics again?
I guess like two.
I feel like the classics.
Yeah, toy Chica is the best version of Chica.
Your what-up does?
Which do you play for that PC?
You can play on your fucking phone?
That's crazy.
Finally, which would you do at Freddy Fazbear?
Freddy Fazbear's pizzeria.
Eat pizza.
It's a pizzeria.
I'll go eat pizza.
Alright.
I'm Freddy!
Okay.
Ah, yes.
Oh, at least I'm the main character.
That's good.
I have main character syndrome.
Yeah, I was like, I'm at a pizzeria.
What the else would I fucking do?
Or, or?
Ah, yes.
The main man.
animatronic.
Freddy is laid back, happy, and easygoing.
At night, he loves to taunt the night guard, singing a song
before a jump scare.
He loves interactive children and hang out with bedspuds,
chicken, and Bonnie.
Yeah, Freddy is laid back, happy, and easygoing.
He literally kills.
Yeah, if you're human, if you're human, he'll kill you, but
you're a fellow animatronic.
Like, The image is no longer available.
Okay, we won't have to do this one yet.
Only nerds with an IQ over 175 can pass this fandom vocab
quiz.
Oh, that is easy.
That is easy.
I'm terminally online.
Okay.
What is a muggle?
A person born with no magical abilities.
Oh, my.
Easy.
Define Vibranium.
I'll go back to this later.
Define Medi-Clorian.
We'll go back to this later.
Define Mockingjay.
Okay.
Fake Rivals.
I always told you guys.
I don't DC more than Marvel.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh, this one.
Yeah, it's genetically engineered bird species that can
mimic human voices and spy on others.
Wait.
No.
Wait, no.
It was first regenerative through the mating.
Oh, mockingbirds.
Yeah.
And Jabberjays.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
See, I remember this.
I remember this.
I didn't read any of the books.
I just remember I watched the movies recently.
I recently like two or three years ago.
All right.
Define kryptonite.
Oh, that's easy.
uh yeah
okay i had to i was like i remember okay i know what
kryptonite is but i was like i didn't realize it emitted
poisonous radiation because like everyone on krypton isn't
like an actual like superhuman um it's just that because the
gravity is so like it's because like he gets his powers from
the sun so like um he doesn't and really it's like people on
crypto and aren't really like superpowered beings and stuff
so i was like thinking like um is it actually poisonous yeah
okay xenomorph all right an alien diet nips okay a parasit i
requires okay that that's that's one yeah a parasitic
extraterrestrial species i know that the fine flux okay i've
never watched to the future i don't i the only thing i know
about it is the fucking car that's the only thing i know
about back to the future and that he almost banged his mom
also rick and morty was inspired about this
there's no and his name is marty m'fly like okay i know a
lot more than i thought okay i actually know a lot more than
i thought i did for back to the future i only know that that
it it inspired rick and morty his name is marty m'fly He
almost banged his mom and then the car because everyone
wants to have the car Apparently, it's getting harder and
harder to build the car now because it's like the parts are
super old and like you know Like when you know the as it
gets older like as the years keep passing by like it's
harder to find the actual parts to make the fucking car The
the the Lord the Delorean right the Delorean the Delorean
Yeah, and he has to go back to the future
I assume it's the one that lets you travel in time.
Oh, yeah.
DeLorean.
Yeah, there you go.
This is the only time travel one.
Define unobtainium.
It's unobtainable.
Oh, yeah.
I remember.
This is like my issue with like, basically James Cameron, it
looks amazing.
The movies look amazing.
But two and three is like one, two, and three are all like
based.
It's literally the same plot.
The unobtainium is unattainable.
That's like, I fucking remember that.
Like, everyone always makes fun of that.
It's so clever.
It's so unobtainable.
Yeah, that's so fucking stupid.
Bro, I don't fucking remember.
I only watched the first avatar movie.
I don't remember.
Okay, I'll come back to this later.
Define Horcrux from Harry Potter.
Uh...
Where is it?
A dark...
An object possess...
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, this one.
Because he won an immortality.
Define droid from the Star Wars universe.
That's me this.
Oh, my God.
Okay, now I just have to go back to all the ones I have.
didn't know okay all right here you go vibranium i know his
shield is made of vibranium and it's not the is that waconda
it's in waconda right oh my god okay i i just know it's in
it's in waconda that's all i remember i was like oh waconda
and mineral yeah never mind okay i'm Apparently, yeah,
Wakanda forever.
I got, I saw Wakanda.
I know it's in Wakanda.
That's the 175.
Okay, the 5-Middeclorian.
I don't fucking, what the fuck is Middeclorian?
Uh.
I don't know this one.
Oh, yeah!
Yeah!
Okay, okay, I just gotta get this one right.
And then I have an IQ of 175.
It's very...
Don't know that.
All right.
Unobtainium.
Okay.
Well, obviously it's extremely rare mineral.
But like they don't know how...
They don't do anything with unobtainium.
I know like the Avatar people don't know what to do with
unobtainium.
That's all I know.
But I know like the military wants it.
Because it's unobtainable.
Yeah.
it's like unobtainable where the fuck are the sky oh my god
it's literally like the avatar there's the fire people
there's the water people oh my god it's literally the avatar
because in the fourth movie we're gonna learn about the sky
avatars now because in the second one we learn about this
first one we learned about the earth avatars second one was
the water avatar third one was the fire and then the fourth
one we're gonna learn about the sky avatars ours now yeah
wait we started with the sky oh then the fourth one no no we
didn't start with the sky because apparently apparently the
sky ones actually live in like floating like like actual
like floating islands like yeah i know like but it's already
a float but there's like there's another there's a floating
floating island yeah no it's like beyond floating it's
beyond the first one
No, there's a different one.
It's another one that actually, like, they fly everywhere.
I was reading about it.
They're like, we're going to learn more about the other, the
flying, the floating island avatars.
And I was like, weren't they already on the floating rocks?
But they're like, apparently there's another avatar.
There's another species of these fucking blue aliens where
they're like, they actually control, like, the land, like,
and stuff.
Yeah, the note, yeah.
Yeah, they, like, hinted about them in Avatar 3 with the
Fire avatars.
So, like, the first one was actually Earth.
The fourth one will actually, like, are actually the flying
ones, the air ones.
That's crazy.
It's literally following the avatar.
Alright.
I don't fucking know this one.
I, like, I don't think anyone actually pays attention to the
plot when they're watching guitar.
It's like an octaneum.
Yeah.
Like, I feel like, I don't know.
I don't know if anyone actually, oh, I did.
I fucking watched it for the fucking plot.
I don't know.
I feel like, okay, it's not engineered.
I'll do process of elimination.
I know it's a rare material.
So it's either two or, it's either three or four.
I know it's not two.
Is that a three or four?
I'll say three because like energy.
Oh yay!
Nine out of ten!
That's like 170 guys.
That's like you scored better at 89% of all the other quiz
takers.
Look at that.
Guys, I'm so fucking smart.
I'm so fucking smart.
smart guys look look at at least 40 people took this quiz
that means i have an iq of over at least 170.
i'm a fucking i told you guys i'm smart as hell at least i'm
smarter than at least 40 percent 40 people who took this one
quiz all right all your good ones All right.
All right.
Break up with your significant other, and we'll reveal which
Brooklyn 99 character you are.
All right.
How do I do this?
Okay.
How do I do a breakup?
Start the breakup.
I have a proposal for you.
We need to cry.
I'll do cry.
I cries.
I think that's the easiest.
and he'll feel sad for me.
Okay, Larry, you've been a good friend.
I feel like, yes, we should separate.
You've been a bit boring lately.
The artists that juiced up Captain America's dumpy for the
big stream are VTubers now.
But yeah, it's C.
Are you serious?
I think it's crazy.
He's like, what's your resume?
I juiced up.
I juiced up Chris Evans' ass.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you.
My body's been telling, you've been a great person to be.
around but we should break up oh my god they're all so bad
this is how humans like i start crying i'm like you're just
so boring like you're just you're so boring
Okay.
Okay, I gotta do that.
Uh, I feel like you're way too bad.
I just can't find time for you.
You're just really weird.
You're always so annoying and introducing me to people who
I'm not ready to see.
You never have time for me.
fucking boring.
Okay.
There's a lot of my play.
I feel like I never see you anymore.
This just won't work.
And I'm not into that.
And I don't really love you anymore.
Holy shit.
This guy's going to have eternal trauma.
I don't want to be with you anymore.
And I'm not into that.
I just can't do this right now.
There's a lot.
I feel like I never see you.
Okay.
This is like the least other than that you're so boring
we're done that's why I want to break up this is the best
option for both of us you're just too boring I'm sorry I'm
sorry emotional damage alright say bye shakes hands
Oh, I'm Captain Hall!
Yay!
I think it's the shake hands part.
I know it's a...
You're boring.
You're a boss, and your breakup tactic is brutally honest
and with zero rewards.
You have more important things to be doing with your time
when dealing with someone who you don't mesh with.
What can I say?
We don't mesh.
We just...
I'll shake your hand at GG's, you know?
GG's, we had a good run.
What the fuck is this?
If you need a hobby, 42 things to help you realize some of
your body-related problems have legit solutions.
All right.
GG, easy.
GG's going decks, you know?
we had a good run all right what else watch us guess your
favorite nugget shape and reveal exactly what it reveals
about your personality okay we gotta figure out what they're
gonna find me a special nugget guys my other story never
take toky thank you for the super chat broken pod thank you
thank you all right choose a cat picture.
I like this cat.
He always looks scared.
Who's a vegetable?
I don't like any of this.
I mean, like, roasted broccoli is... Steam broccoli and
roasted broccoli is really good.
So I'll choose that.
Choose a console.
I'm not going to get baited by nostalgia, so say
PlayStation.
PlayStation 2 was my favorite console.
Who's a stuffed animal?
This guy.
He looks very quirky.
a snack macarons and now call yellow and animal panda choose
one last random photo this because this is you guys you guys
are over here i'm a boot shaped i'm a boot shaped chicken
nuggy all right what does a boot shaped nugget tell say
about me all right that here's someone say your ideal nugget
shape is a poop which means you're a very direct no nonsense
person you're feared more than your love and you're okay
what is that let's go oh my god guys these bus speed
questions are these bus speed quizzes are so fucking
accurate guys no fucking wonder they were so
oh my god they know they know my fucking soul all right wait
didn't i just do this wait this is a new one okay wait this
is let's test my canadian okay let's do this again it's
another canadian quiz how most americans can even score five
out of 26 on a super easy A to Z Canadian trivia test.
All right.
Just I'm taking a test again.
It's like, you know, driver's license.
You got to take a test.
You got to retake the test and make every like couple of
years to make sure you're a real Canadian.
So I have to come back and take the test again just to be
sure.
What's this phenomenon called?
Oh, the War of Orialis.
That's easy.
Versation right here in the middle of in your kitchen.
Okay.
What is this food called?
Oh, it's a beaver's tail!
That shit's good!
It's literally like a pastry with whatever the fuck you want
to put on top.
That's literally it.
And it looks like a beaver's tail.
Like the pastry looks like a be- it's like fried pastry.
And then like you can put like, like Nutella or like
whatever you want.
I like Nutella and bananas on top.
It's so good.
It's actually like a- it's like it's actually really fucking
good.
Yeah, because it looks like a tail.
Okay, Canadian coroner, Akerabu.
We had that lesson earlier, too.
We actually, we had that lesson.
That's why I'm like, why is the fucking 10 cents a goddamn
boat?
I don't understand.
We were doing so well with animals.
And then we just put a fucking boat.
I fucking put a random boat on it.
What is the nickname for coffee?
Order it with two.
Okay, actually, I don't know what this is.
Double drip.
Double, double.
Okay, how is that?
Oh, it's only a Tim Hortons.
Who the fuck goes to Tim Hortons anymore?
I don't think who the fuck goes to Tim Hortons for coffee.
Like, it's like, it's shitty coffee.
Not the double down.
Like, the only reason I go to Tim Hortons or Timmy's is for
ice caps and the donuts.
And the Timmy's, Timbits.
Timbits and ice caps the coffees fucking suck at Tim Hortons
what might I don't know when I start going to Tim Hortons
it's so fucking bad yeah what's the Edmonton's foot bro who
the fuck cares about Edmonton I'm here for the Canucks bro
what's the if we have a football team like I'm sorry If you
live in Edmonton, I'm sorry.
But like, they have a football team.
I thought that would exist in America.
For real.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry if you live in Edmonton.
I didn't even know.
I didn't even know you guys have.
There was a Canadian League?
Like, I wouldn't understand it because it's like hockey.
But like...
We have, who's watching Canadian football?
You now watch the CFL.
I don't know.
I guess the Elks.
I was like, that's the most Canadian animal.
I was like, Eagles are American.
I don't think they care about emeralds.
And like, I don't know.
Why is it called Edison?
So when Thomas Edison is American, Elka seems the most
Canadian.
Oh my God, there is a Canadian football team.
Oh my god, we have a thing called CFL.
We have the top 10 biggest malls here, girl, in Edmonton.
Sonny, man.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
I didn't even realize we have a league.
I thought it was just America.
It's like how like the national, the, the, like, like, you
know, all like the basketball.
The top basketball, football, and baseball teams are all
just situated in America.
What is the longest river Fraser?
That's the only river I recognize.
I don't know any of these other rivers.
Yeah, there we go.
What food was invented in Canada?
Oh, Graham Kra- Oh!
Okay, never mind.
Never mind.
The ginger beef.
Oh my god, we did this.
We invented ginger beef.
That was, I thought I was graham crackers.
It felt Canadian.
Graham crackers was in fact invented in the US.
Okay.
Oh, that's, I'm sad that we invented ginger beef.
It was you.
I thought it was like orange chicken.
What is Canada's national sport?
Hockey, of course.
Hockey is cat.
Our summer sport is lacrosse.
Wait, more summer sports.
Sport is lacrosse, really?
I know that's true.
That's true.
It is like hockey, but on grass.
That's actually, it's like instead of the puck being like on
ice, it's like in the net.
That's fucking...
Let me fucking give...
Oh, my.
That's so sad.
Oh, that's so sad.
lacrosse is our summer sport it's like um what is that it's
like what is that sport where uh you sweep it with a broom
on ice what is it called i forgot what sport was that you
start sweeping the the ice with brooms and stuff curling
yeah yeah it's like curling we have like we we like we love
what's the structure called I know what this is I just don't
know the name Oh this is bad I don't know Yay I guess it
works I guess it works I know it was built by the Inuit
people I was just like I never like learned the name of this
What's the name of the Canadian music Wait we have a
Canadian music award show Okay Oh, the Junos.
Okay, the Juno Awards.
Yeah, see?
As much as I'm rooting for Names, we change our jangles.
Our Fusing Award is called the Juno Awards.
Well, that's something new I learned.
The Juno Awards.
Ketchup.
Yeah!
Okay, I know that.
Jingle, jangle.
Yeah, we're infamous for our ketchup chips.
We love ketchup on our chips for some reason.
um oh we don't apparently if you bring them you will not be
in but never mind apparently we we don't love them but we
still eat them which canadian author oh my god we just
learned about this it was like she had a long name it was
that yeah we literally just learned about this oh the mownie
the mownie police i know that what's this dessert called oh
wait the naimo bar yeah i've never tried it before, but like
I always see like cafes.
I still, I don't know what this tastes like.
Um, I have no idea what this tastes like, but I always see
this in like cafes and stuff.
What does it taste like anyway?
They look really good.
It looks like lemon in the middle.
I have no idea what it tastes like, but I always see this at
my craft cafe.
It's like chocolate, coconut, and custard.
Oh, that sounds so good.
I should try that next time.
But I from a very own enamel bc oh super creamy custard
filling and a chocolate oh chocolate cookie base custard in
the middle and then a chocolate top okay that sounds really
fucking good it sounds really sweet but also really good at
the same time what lake but this person it looks like this
person like is from bc i know all the questions is like
situated in british columbia um what lake set to inhabit oh
wait okopogo i remember this okopogo yeah this guy this guy
he's this is our like resident uh we have our own nesting
monster yeah he's like you know there's like Loch Ness
monster uh we have our own and it's called his name is
okopogo he looks he's a goofy guy he's a goofy guy he
doesn't he doesn't kill What is this dish called?
Okay, what was printed on the back of Canadian?
Oh, Queen Elizabeth, the...
Wait, we got rid of her?
Wait, what is it now?
Wait, what?
Wait!
We got rid of Queen Elizabeth the second...
She's our queen forever!
It's Doki, she's...
That doesn't matter!
What?
That doesn't matter.
The king doesn't own Canada.
We don't care.
What the fuck has King Charler's done for us?
Like, who's gonna tell her that Queen Elizabeth is?
Bro, oh my, wait, really?
Okay, wait, wait.
Canada coins 2024.
There's no fucking way they replaced it with the goddamn
king.
Oh my god, they fucking did.
Oh, Oh my god!
Don't keep that treason.
Oh my god, they did!
They replaced her!
I'm so sad!
I can't believe they would do that to Queen Elizabeth II!
You know what's cool?
You see her age in our coins, like when she gets older.
I'll show you guys.
Like, as she gets older, they actually change, like, the
coin to, like, reflect their being old.
That's actually crazy.
Like, Queen Elizabeth, coin, Canada.
I like that.
It was, like, I thought it was really cool that they did
that.
And so you can be like, oh, my God, this is when she was
like, when she was free.
first queen.
I can't believe they changed it.
Why would they do such a thing?
I think is this the right one?
Yeah.
So as she gets older, the coins like matched her age,
basically.
I think this was, I don't know if this was the Canadian one.
It's close enough.
Wait, it might be this one.
There you go.
yeah bro of course she was oh she like out she like was
queen for like like like when america had six different
presidents she was queen for all six of them you would see
like pictures of her like next to the president of the
united states of america would like for like six plus
presidents
i can't believe it now i shouldn't say that's treason
Now what, Toki?
Now what's going on with the...
I have nothing.
Long live the king.
You're making it sound like she has lived.
Nothing.
Which famous person is not from Canada?
Okay, Reynolds and Rogan.
I know, Seth Rogan's actually Canadian.
I think Keanu... It's either Keanu Reeves or Meg.
I have no idea who the fuck Meg Ryan is.
It's either of these two.
I feel like it should be Keanu Reeves, right?
Oh, it's Meg Ryan's?
Keanu Reeves is Canadian?
Oh my god.
I did not know he was Canadian.
He's living in America for so fucking I don't know who Meg
Ryan is.
What the fuck does she do?
Meg Ryan.
I was like, I don't know who she is.
When Harry...
I have not...
Oh, she did...
I have not watched any of these movies.
All the movies she's done is like rom-coms and then Top Gun.
I've never watched Top Gun.
I just knew...
I never watched...
I barely watched rom-coms.
The only rom-coms I've ever watched was...
50 First Dates Fucking love that movie Um And I think that's
it I think that's like the Best rom-coms I think that's like
the only rom-com movie I've ever fucking watched in my life
There's like a I know there's like a lot of them be like
Well why didn't you watch that It's like I'm not a fan of
rom-coms She's the man She's the man 50 First Dates
Um Forgetting Sarah Marshall, that movie was good.
And that's it.
Yeah, I've never watched anything else.
Wait, is the 40-year-old version also on Rom-Con?
Because I've watched that one.
Music and lyrics!
Oh my god, I remember music and lyrics.
I love the songs and music and lyrics.
That one was really good.
But that, I'm looking through the list.
But yeah, that's everything I recognize on the list.
I did not realize Kiyom.
Gano Reeves was, was Canadian, or is Canadian.
He's still alive.
I feel like he's been, like, in America for so long.
Pop goes my heart goes hard.
It goes fucking hard.
He's just, it's because, like, he's been, he's been, like,
in Hollywood for so fucking long that I didn't even realize
he's Canadian.
I know Reynolds and Rogan is Canadian.
Also, like, his, everyone knows him because he's, like,
past, just, like, So sad.
Also, I had no idea who the fucking Meg Ryan was.
What are these periods called?
The fuck is that?
The Saskatchewan?
Is it Saskatoon?
Okay, it's the province of Canada.
Yeah, it's the Saskatchewan.
The fucking entire province of Canada.
up.
This is really the province.
What Canadian band is this?
What the fuck?
Tragically hip, the temp taken by trees.
Tangerine dream.
Okay.
Oh, I don't know.
What the fuck are these names?
I don't know.
I would say tangerine dreams because that's a good, that's a
fucking okay.
I'd say taken by trees.
The Tragically hip.
I would say tanger.
Oh my god, the tragedy hip.
Okay, that's the tragically hip from a city not to not to
what the fuck?
Got bookcase.
That I don't know.
That does not seem like a good name.
Taken by trees.
Present performing tonight at CPC.
Taken by tree.
which region occupied was now northern quebec from 18 i
don't bro i don't pay attention to quebec i can't
believe they're not called tangerine dreams that's a good
ass name i don't know okay on gava also the name of my
favorite canadian gin okay i i don't know I don't know
anything about the Quebecois.
I just know that they tried to be their own, like, sovereign
state.
That's all I know.
And they had their own Canadian party.
Well, Canadian city pays homage to a science fiction
franchise.
Oh, Vulcan.
Yeah, that's Star Trek shit.
Like, I don't know what these three are, but, like, I assume
it's Vulcan just because it's Star Trek.
Come to Alberta.
Oh, so they have a town for the Vulcans Oh wait West
Edmonton mall from the super chatter from Zonderman.
Thanks Zonderman Thanks for letting me pass my Canadian test
Bro, you have a fucking what?
You have a water park in your goddamn mall.
Okay, that's fucking crazy That's insane You have a fucking
water park at your own mall.
What wasn't filmed in Canada?
Bro, what?
Why is, why do people, what?
X, X?
Okay, I was gonna say, what the fuck is, okay, X files,
X-Men, and X-Men, the last staff, was all filmed in Canada.
We just really love X films, guys.
Yeah, I was gonna say, what movie is X?
I assume X, right?
I don't even know.
That was a real movie.
Oh my god, that even is a real movie.
Y'all love our tax breaks in Canada.
What is the capital city of the northwest, the Yukon?
Okay, I don't know.
The Yukon was the only thing I recognized.
We truly have some of the best city names.
What is this?
Oh, uh, Zamboni!
Yeah!
Let's go!
I passed my Canadian test again, guys.
I fucking did it.
Yeah, this is kind of a Zamboni.
I knew this.
found out this was called a Zamboni from Deadpool from the
first Deadpool movie and that works because Ryan Reynolds
was in Deadpool and he's Canadian so he taught me about the
Zamboni I passed my citizenship test guys I get to keep my
Canadian passport again yay I did it alright alright let's
try
this here are 50 states and I can be impressed if you find
50 of them oh wait are these all 50 states okay we're not
doing that we're not oh my god that hurts my ass oh my god
all right yeah we're not that's 50 that's way too many
states okay i i gotta use the bathroom guys i'll be right
back but we're gonna do fill your plate with cartoon foods
and will receive real which animated world you i already
forgot where colorado is guys i already uh but we're gonna
we're gonna do fill your plate with cartoon foods and we'll
reveal which anime world you belong in i'll be right back
though i gotta use the bathroom
all right i'm back it's time to figure out which animation
made a word i belong in uh mega hippo sword gordon zekra
factor maul burr lecon wb forward papa digs bite size
neppers allen solid many thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
I learned what the name of Zamboini is from a blog review of
Batman and Robin.
That's funny.
That's like so random, too.
He's like, that's where Zamboinis are from.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright.
Oh, someone's like, did you watch?
Yes, I watched my hands.
That's crazy.
That person that was it the best ad, the best, like, free
shout out for those 3D trackers.
And then she didn't wash her hands And then her fucking
channel got suspended I assume because she peed on stream So
then Twitch was like I assume that's why she got banned
Apparently like there was this girl Who was like She was
like oh I didn't She was like trying to during the middle of
her 3D stream She got like Suspended Like she like went to
use the bathroom But she didn't realize that her trackers
were tracking her when she went to the bathroom because it
was like really far away um and then she didn't realize the
range was that far um it was like the best like free ad that
the tracker company ever got because of it because they're
like oh my god it works even that far away um and then she
didn't wash your hands and everybody was like oh my god she
also didn't wash your hands after she peed but the thing was
um right after that her her channel got bad she got she got
that and people assume that it's because you're not
technically you're not allowed to show yourself being you
know because it's like against the terms of service because
like she wasn't streaming anything else other than that so
twitch suspended her her twitch account all right but yeah
no apparently um the um the free ad like the what is it
called the product placement was so good like the um for it
like it was just just a good way to advertise this product
that they actually sold out because of it like everyone
bought the trackers because it's like really cheap too it's
like it's like what was it it was like less than a hundred
dollars or something was it less yeah it was like less than
a hundred dollars or something yeah free advertisement it's
like a hundred or two it's either less than a hundred or a
hundred and two hundred uh which is like really cheap for uh
for trackers yeah because like vibe trackers are so fucking
expensive in general so the fact that it's cheaper that is
cheaper than vibe trackers and like uh it's 260 or was i
don't remember i just remember it was like really cheap for
for like six plus trackers or something would you try what
food from 200 is really good for 3d tracking for like six
plus trackers because it's like uh yeah six to seven
trackers for 200 because like vibe trackers are like for
everything you gotta get the base stations you gotta get
like the individual tracker things that you have to wear um
you have to get the Um, because I need to get, like, three
base stations instead of two.
Um, and then you have to get the individual tracker things
and get three of them.
They're, like, 300, they're, like, at least $400.
And that's three trackers.
I remember it's, like, at least 400.
I just don't remember how much it was in total.
What fruit from SpongeBob would you try if you're given the
chance?
I want a crabby patty.
Okay.
I tried the I tried the Burger King crabby patty and yet it
wasn't it oh wait let me grab tissues real quick too I
didn't blow my nose
yeah it was just a it was just a square it was just a square
burger but like the bird the patty was so dry but like a
crabby patty is like homemade so it should be like you know
not fast food because
it's homemade by sponge bob it's literally like the crusty
crab is in a fast food restaurant they forgot to add the
love okay choose a dish from ratatouille i will say the
omelet only because okay ratatouille they like make it sound
so good but my first got when i finally got ratatou in real
life it's literally just vegetables like cut together like
it's like a vegetable like it's just vegetables just clamped
up together it's there it's not it's nothing it's like i
rather just get omni it's like they made it sound like it's
like some fucking like like exquisite cuisine it's like
bougie so fucking fancy and then it's just it's just a It's
just a hot, a warm vegetable salad.
Yeah.
They look so good in a movie, though.
Pick up food from the Simpsons.
Oh, my God.
Okay, you know how, like...
Um...
Yeah, I remember it was like peasant food because, like, um,
in the end, it's like...
What was it?
He, like, it reminded him back when he was young.
And that's what, like, it gave him a flashback of a back but
then they made it look so fucking good and then all the
fancy restaurants started selling ratatouille too i think
because of the because of the movie buff like if you ever go
to french restaurants they'll sell ratatouille or some shit
and then like so i was like oh ratatouille and then like it
was not not the best also like rib which is oh my god steam
hams i want I was steamed abs.
But Rib Witch is like based off of what was that?
What was that McDonald's burger?
Magrib?
I tried a Magrib the last time I was in America because I
always see everyone.
Because like the Magrib is you can only get the Magrib in
America.
Like we don't have them in Canada.
And like I don't it's it's pretty mid I'm like it's pretty
there's so I would it's pretty mid I was like I don't know
if every time you know like family guy and the Simpsons are
always talking about like the McRib and then like you know
like the family guy clip where he's like oh my god it's back
guys it's back did you hear like I heard I heard this is it
guys what we practiced before Yeah, it's McMib.
I would say the McRib is pretty McMib.
The McRib is back.
You know what's good?
Okay, I want to try steamed ham, so pick up food from Jibli.
Now, Jibli knows how to make good food.
Um...
Hmm.
Wait, that's an onigiri?
What the fuck?
I did not realize that it's an onigiri.
I would say the breakfast.
I want the breakfast.
I want Calcifer's breakfast.
I don't know.
Kiki's pancakes?
I'm not a huge fan of pancakes.
I like Belgium waffles more than pancakes, to be fair.
The Ponyos ham ramen.
but then I saw like someone recreated that, but it's just
instant ramen.
Like Literally, it's just like... I like Belgium waffles
more than pancakes.
Or it's either Belgium waffles or um Or Japanese pancakes
because they're more fluffy But I know this isn't Japanese
pancakes because it's like regular pancakes because it's
like based off of...
I assume like this is based off of Europe.
Like right?
Kiki's delivery service?
right?
Because the book was, a lot of people who don't know this,
but a lot of the films that Stoogibli do adaptations on is
just based off of like European stories, like European like
novels or children's books.
So a lot of the stories are based in like actually in
Europe, like the original novels that it comes from.
Yeah, because like they're not original movies.
A lot of the Aren't original films.
They're actually like adaptations of like, like novels and
stuff.
Or children's books.
Yeah.
Because some people think it's like original films, but
they're not.
It's like how Lady and the Tramp.
It's like how Disney did a lot of them were based off of
like novels, adaptations.
It's like Lady and the Tramp was originally based off.
of a book and like originally like none of like like Walt
Disney had to like hard push for uh I think it was like I
think okay I think I remember I'm trying to remember the
story about this but um because I I have the I have the
platinum I used to own the platinum DVD of Lady and the
Tramp you know they always do like back then I don't know
they still do it but Disney will release DVDs and then
they'll be like, oh, it's going to go to Disney Vault.
Don't buy it.
And it'll be like platinum edition, diamond edition, gold
edition of various movies.
And he's like, if you don't buy it, we're going to put it in
the Disney Vault.
So I had like the platinum edition of Lady in the Tramp.
And like, I think it was like, like Walt Disney wanted to do
an original film, but people were like, um, yeah.
So basically it was originally an original story.
And, That was pitched to Walt Disney and he really wanted to
do it But then like the board was like no Because like we've
always done like adaptations of stuff We're like he like has
like visors and stuff We're like don't do it It's too risky
We've always done adaptations And then he told the writer to
He told the writer to publish a book about this So he can
like do like an adaptation of it So, like, to do, like, a
loophole, being like, see, it's an adaptation, guys.
The book was published.
It's not an original story.
Yeah, so they're like, he's like, guys, see?
It's not an original story, guys.
It's a book.
It's from a book.
Yeah.
Yeah, 4D chess move.
Fun facts with Doki.
I was a...
I'm not a Disney adult.
I was a Disney child.
that's different I was a Disney child not a Disney adult I
just really I really like Disney back then oh yeah I would
say that's why I won't pick the ramen only because like um
because like I saw someone recreate it and it was just
instant ramen I'd rather have like ramen ramen because like
that's what it was it was Ponyo like Ponyo the mom just made
instant ramen for her and then cut like So I'll take the
I'll take You can't really mess up bacon and eggs
Or only Gary But it depends on what this is I don't know
what that is in the filling Because there's some fillings I
don't like I would say the bento But this I know I forgot
what this is called But I'm not a fan of this Top part over
here And I hate pie I'm sorry I'm not a fan of pie I never
really like pie I never really like pie it's a donut of
course it's jelly filled donut
i know it's the eggs but it's not actual row it's not like
the normal row you see on sushi it's a different type of row
and i never like that type of row so i'm gonna go with i
will go with bacon and eggs from for my colorado heart I'm
not a huge fan there's like I'm very picky with instant
ramen I rather do because like if I had to choose between
instant ramen or instant udon I will pick instant udon
versus instant ramen I just feel like um I just love or like
mix or like mixed ramen like the microwave ramen where you
um I just got like because like I when I lived in Asia
there's so many different types of like um instant ramen or
like instant udon so there's lots of choices it wasn't just
like instant ramen so microwave ramen where it's like where
it's like um it's um you like do like mix some sauce in the
mix some sauce in the ramen and then you pour some water and
then you microwave it and it's so good there's like
carbonara ramen and shit like that it's so fucking good so
that's why I'm like for me I'm not like an instant ramen
like just the broth instant ramen type thing I just I I like
like if I had to choose like broth kind where I have to have
the broth in there I would choose instant Udom versus
instant ramen.
No, no, there's like, it's like specific, because it's like,
um, it's like a mixed ramen thing.
Um, and it's like, basically, you put a little bit of water,
and then you mix it, you put like, it's like, um, um, it's
like, it's like, you have to microwave it, um, too.
It's not like you can't, uh, I don't remember what it's
called, but it was one of my favorite instant ramen, so
they're so good.
Pick a Disney movie food The gray What the fuck is the gray
stuff Okay I'm pro por I don't know Like the gray stuff I
know it's like French cuisine Oh what is up Arepe con queso
Who picks It's apparently delicious delicious.
Pick the great stuff.
It's delicious.
I want the spinach puff from Cusco.
From Crank.
Don't believe me?
Ask the dishes.
I want to try Crank's great stuff.
Not great stuff.
Crank's spinach puffs because he's always talking about how
good it is.
Yeah.
did you guys see the video of like him and his sons like um
because it was like the anniversary or something for
emperor's new group and then they like invited Crock the
voice like what's his name I remember his name um like
literally he is like he is the he only does one voice but
what it is the best voice ever like but his and his sons
came with him and they're like alright we're gonna see if
your sons can replicate like can voice act like the role of
Crock basically, yeah Patrick Ryan uh warbord yeah yeah and
then like they actually sound like him and one of his sons
is a voice actor too so like whenever like he retires his
son can literally take over and just do his voice it's
literally just it's like i don't care that he gets
typecasted or like he can only do one voice it is a really
good voice it is a peter hey pick some food from me
Um...
Uh...
From a Cartoon Network show.
Cookie Cat.
Oh, Bacon Pancakes!
Making Bacon Pancakes!
I want Bacon Pancakes.
I know I say I don't like pancakes, but I think I would like
Bacon Pancakes from Jake the Dog.
I love that song.
Making Bacon Pancakes 100%.
I choose a food from Bluey!
Okay, I've never watched Bluey before, but okay.
Oh, that Christmas ham looks so fucking good.
I'm grabbing the Christmas ham.
That ham.
That is just chips.
That is mashed potatoes, chips, and popcorn.
I don't fuck with that.
It's like that Snoopy Christmas dinner where it's just jelly
beans.
Jelly beans and fucking mashed potatoes.
Like, yeah.
All right, pick a food from a Nickelodeon cartoon.
The Magic Muffin.
I don't remember what the Magic Muffin did.
Oh, it's magical.
So surely that'll give me something.
Surely that'll give me some magical powers.
Pick some food from a Sony movie.
Misanya.
Where is my pipe?
Okay.
Misanya, please.
Oh, gives you rule-free wishes?
I picked a good one.
Choose some food from a DreamWorks movie.
Roast.
What movie is that?
Wait.
This is DreamWorks?
There's no way.
No, Wallace and Gromit just has his own studio.
Oh, is that Shrek?
Oh, yeah, that's Shrek right there.
I see him.
What?
Wait, Wallace and Gromit is owned by DreamWorks?
I did not know that.
Oh, it was funded by DreamWorks.
I'm going to do dumplings.
I'm on Pixar!
Oh, no.
Is it pre?
Okay, but is it pre-sequel Pixar or like...
Or after-sequel Pixar, though.
Which Pixar is it?
There's...
Yeah, pre-merge Pixar or after-merge Pixar.
The world has way of making everything seem beautiful and
hopeful.
Even death, toys come to life, robots fall in love, and a
rat cooks for your meals.
Yeah!
Okay, it's pre-merge Pixar.
So it was 20.
Well, so it was good, but it was just, it didn't get the
hype because it released during covet era it should have
deserved more attention i feel like so was really fucking
good but yeah like i said um it just released at a bad time
same with like was it on kanto on kanto is disney it's not
pixar but it released during a bad time where it just was
just like in disney plus only um so like so like not a lot
of people talked about it till after yeah yeah all right
inside out two i don't understand how inside two made so
much fucking money but like inside out two was literally
like inside out one but like it's like joy never learned her
lesson it's literally like it's like they're like we all
learned a lesson today in inside out one and then in inside
out two it's like anyway we forgot our lesson so let's redo
all of this again Like, yeah.
That's the thing.
I watched Inside Out, too.
I wasn't like, I wasn't a fan of it.
But apparently it made more money than Inside, the first
Inside Out.
And it was like, it was like a box.
It was like, it broke the top 10 for animated movies for
that year.
Um, but like, like she, she was, it was just not a, I'm not
a huge, I wasn't a huge fan of Inside Out, too.
Like the story was.
Um.
and like uh what is it
it is really big internationally i won't be surprised if it
was because i know inside out was is really popular in asia
same with zutopia 2.
zutopia 2 is like the most popular animated movie that
disney has ever made i think so far
as of international market uh market for those who don't
know i personally thought The plot of Zootopia 2, I was not
a fan of, like, certain parts of the plot for Zootopia 2.
And I hated the twist villain.
I was not a fan of it being another twist villain.
Because the last, I swear to God, ever since...
since Frozen all we get is twist villains and I'm fucking
tired of that shit like it's just it's like Frozen big hero
6 um Zootopia 2 I can name so many but I need like fucking
pull up a list because no one keeps tracking modern Disney
anymore there's no good villains I love good villains and
like every Disney modern Disney movie is just twist villains
ever since fucking Hans because everyone was like, oh, Hans,
you know?
Oh yeah, Coco.
All right, Coco twist villain was actually good because you
get to, there's a build up.
I think the thing about Coco's twist villain is that there
was foreshadowing that he was a twist villain, you know?
Um, like for Coco, like you could tell like there's
something wrong with that guy.
Like, because you, you know, he's like, um, you're my
grandpa.
And he was like, you know, and then they kept hiding he's
not the grandpa is he and so then you're like so there's
like a build up to it for the like it like for the twist
villain but like um there's like like big hero six was like
fucking out of nowhere hans was out of nowhere he's like i'm
so good i'm such a nice guy uh and also like for coco the
twist villain for coco um it was more so of like um also
coco it was like it's not like fully Disney too.
But like for Coco for the twist villain, like even at the
beginning he was like super egotistical and everything like
you could tell.
Like they were saying like oh yeah like he's like super
egotistical and everything so you know he's not like that
good of a guy.
So like when he turns out he was a villain you're like oh
yeah yeah that makes sense.
Like yeah
but like a lot of of the modern Disney films and modern
Pixar films like it's like even I would say even like Toy
Story 3 when they made like the oh yeah by the way the bear
is so fucking popular in Asia I have no idea why I think
it's because he's a teddy bear and like Japan loves teddy
bears in general like um a lot of things like that's not
popular in America is so fucking popular in Japan like I
know like a lot so yeah lots so is like so popular in in
Japan specific specifically to there's like so much merch of
lots so in Japan and also um lots so Ted uh Ted the bear yes
the Seth McFarland Ted is very popular in Japan as well and
there's like this teddy bear series in Tokyo Disneyland I
forgot what's his name is but he used to be a originally it
was supposed to be a mascot um in in america but he didn't
do so well so they just but he was super popular in japan
and kept it there i won't forget how wish's villain had a
great point was like okay now he's getting too relatable
turn him bad but stop the super chat thank you thank you oh
my god you're one of a few people that actually watch wish
like yeah duffy duffy he didn't do well in america he didn't
test so well in america but he he tested really well in
japan so they like kept him there cafe for Ted.
That's how popular he is in Japan.
Yeah, so that's why I was like, I'm just tired of twist
villains in general.
Like, they just don't know.
They just, like, just don't know how to write good villains
anymore.
Like, the classic villains, the classic Disney villains, you
know how, like, villains are so popular in Disneyland, or,
like, just Disney in general, like, with all the merch being
like, oh, I love villains.
But they're always from old Disney, the classic Disney,
never in modern Disney, because they just don't know how to
write good villains.
Because, classic Disney The villains are actually evil.
There's no redemption for them.
And that's fine.
Like, I'm fine with that.
Let them be evil.
Like, yeah.
Like, we don't care.
Like, they don't need redemption.
Some people are just evil.
Like, just embrace, they're, like, just embrace, embrace it.
I love Jack Corner.
I always talk about it.
I always, like, somehow always bring up Jack Corner.
But he was dead.
He's, like, my favorite villain.
Like, he's my favorite modern villain.
He's like, how did you become a villain?
Oh, not much.
Just have a great family, rich, you know.
I love Puss in Boots villains.
They are so good at writing.
Okay, I will say Puss in Boots is so good at writing
villains.
Whoever the writers are who make the villains for Puss in
Boots.
Puss in Boots won with the fucking Humpty Dumpty.
always there that's such a good clip i like he left that
clip he's like that's right i was always there and he's just
like bro and all the clips of him like fucking like he was
there he was always there and then and then push and boots
too with jack harider and also literal death himself too
scene.
Oh yeah, you're getting a new Strek.
I don't know how I feel about it.
I don't know.
Like Zendaya's gonna be the daughter.
Strek.
I don't know how I feel about it.
Me when watching Doki get me to take you with the super
chat.
Thank you.
I don't know.
Yeah, Zendaya's gonna be the daughter.
One of the daughters.
But I'm like, what about his two sons, you know?
Why did it focus on Zenday?
Because then it's like, because like, you could tell where
it's heading for because it's like um, because she's a
teenager now.
She's a teenager now.
So you're like thinking, where the fuck is it heading
towards?
Like, is it like Shrek dealing with a teenager, like Like,
Shrek is going to be dealing with having a teenage daughter.
And then I'm, like, I'm a little sketchy about that.
Just a little sketchy about that part.
Because I'm like, oh, it's going to be a, like, how do I
handle having a teenage daughter?
Yeah.
And, like, have a teenage kid.
Oh, yeah.
toy story 5 oh my god okay so they released um they released
like a teaser image of toy story 5 so the plot of toy story
5 is that um they they're doing like a thing where the the
new kid the new kid gets like a like a fucking e-reader or
some shit like those kid e-readers like leapfrog e-readers
oh my i used to have a leapfrog i love that shit um it was
so fun when it, like, it reads stuff out to you and stuff.
So anyway, it's like a, like a E-toy or some shit, like an
iPad.
And so like, they're like, the toys are like, what do we do?
And it was so fucking, it was so funny because, like, Woody
is there.
And people are like, why the fuck is Woody there?
They're like, what's the point of, like, Woody leaving the
gang in Toy Story 4.
And then in Toy Story 5, he's back.
Why is he back?
You're like, did you want to explore the world?
Like, I thought you retired from being a toy.
And you're going to explore the world with your girlfriend.
With your, with your, like, girlfriend.
Why are you back?
Yeah.
Yeah, he left the gang.
He left the gang in Toy Story 4.
Because he, like, wanted to, like, join the circus and,
like, explore this, I guess, like, travel around.
America with his girlfriend with Bo Peep and then five they
show a picture of Woody and Buzz together and I'm like
what's he had an entire arc where he was trying to decide if
he should go he should stay with his like you know stay with
the toys or like go and um or like explore the explore
America with Bo Peep and he chose Bo Peep and then I'm like
so why I was like how is he back like
Bros before bows.
But in fact, they already did this plot line in that Toy
Story that time forgot TV special.
Thank you, the Super Chat star.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, so I don't know.
It's gonna be interesting.
Alright, how messy are you?
Okay, I'll let you guys judge me.
How messy are you, Ashley?
I do not make my bed.
I personally, okay, hear me out.
I personally don't see a point of making your bed if you're
just gonna be like, going back on your bed like who the fuck
is gonna look at your bed like who's gonna look at your bed
you're just gonna go back in there and sleep on it anyway so
what's the point like I don't understand this
dumb shit on your bed and slept in it okay I've never done
that that one I draw the line on that step well she's just
creamy butter change them nope that's that's fucking gross
mattresses are fucking disgusting you like whenever you
change your match to change your and you see that mattress
underneath that is you don't want to look at that you don't
that you don't it's fucking nasty you don't want to look at
your fucking mattress left clothes dry around the house for
days and only pick them up as you wore them i would leave it
in the no like like it was a dirty clothes i just put it
like in the washing machine Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah,
definitely for sure.
Yeah, that's me.
Okay, we had that happen before.
We had that happen before.
I can't lie about this.
I talked about this.
I talked about it.
Yeah.
yeah oh my god why is it all bold
okay not i don't know no no i don't know what this is but
this does not seem
no i i threw away trash that that the trash is like so easy
to throw away it's literally like i live in an apartment
it's literally downstairs no okay does it count like when
i'm like packing i'm packing and then like i come like i
just like you know i'm pack my like i have to pack my
suitcase and stuff oh that does does that count when i'm
packing i put stuff on my bed yeah packing is different okay
yeah like when i'm packing i put all my stuff on my bed and
then like to see what i want if i don't want i just put on
my bed and then just put the stuff I want and then like and
then only when I come back for my trip I unpack like I pack
unpack everything else okay no I need to sit on my chair no
I don't no uh okay I did do that for my closet I'll say that
only like um when I had to unpack my my suitcase I was like
So I just didn't want to bother And I put some stuff on the
floor And I came back and fixed it Because I have one
suitcase And I was like And I don't, sometimes I don't
unpack my suitcase And so And then when I'm like, when I
have to go on a trip I'm like, oh shit!
And then like, I You know, I pack my suitcase like a couple
hours Before my flight And then I like throw everything out
It's like, oh, there's my one suitcase Gotta see what's in
there drop your towel ew no I do not do that that's actually
gross bro the floor is fucking disgusting especially in the
bathroom I just hang it back I do not do this I don't
understand people who keep I'm sorry like the bathroom floor
is fucking disgusting
undressed in a place that's not your bedroom oh yes yes I
have this is to all the women out there you ever just like
you know know take off your bra like you know when you're
like just not in your bedroom and you just you do the the
women's strat like you that you learn in the pe locker room
where you can like when you're like embarrassed and all the
changing rooms are taken in the girl's bathroom during pe so
then you have to like take out you're trying to change and
then you do the thing where like you you put your arms
through your shirt and then you like take off the bra
through that and then like you take the bra off under your
shirt that's what i do you women get it right basically
women have a superpower where you can take off your bra
under their shirt like nothing comes off and then you just
slip the bra under the shirt out and that's throwing a floor
like like because i'm like because i'm like i'll put it in
i'll put in the washer after i'm done
annoying when you want to like relax sometimes you don't
notice it and sometimes when you want to relax you notice it
a lot
undressed in your bedroom but left your clothes no have to
smell your clothes do you have your shoes while walk what
how is that messy always take your shoes up
what how is that a messy tree that's normal if you're
walking in your shoe like in your house
past the doorway
you know while walking through wait but how is it messy
oh so do i check it or uncheck this i don't understand this
question
okay i'm just gonna check it because like that's doesn't
relate to me this doesn't relate to me i'm gonna check it
well i should just left them on the rack until you use them
again i don't have a rack i don't have a dish rack so like
that doesn't apply to me spill something no i fucking clean
it up right away no i didn't want that to stain drop
something not pick it up some okay it depends on what i drop
but sometimes yes not sorted out straight away no i don't
want like uh i have a dishwasher i have a dishwasher i don't
like i don't need to do that i don't have a dish rack
because i have a dish ralash here
broken something not sorted i opened something with litter
and didn't put the lid back on no that's how you get mold my
sir i accidentally forgot to i did do it one time and it was
recently too it was for my sriracha i didn't realize i
didn't fully close the sriracha like the the the lid thing
it's not even lid it's like you know like a twisting i
didn't twist it all the way there okay i did it one time i
didn't realize sriracha expires too But I looked at it.
I was like, why is there like stains on my sriracha bottle?
And I was like, that has to be mold.
That was like, I've never seen like this weird ass stain in
my sriracha bottle before.
And then like, I'm pretty sure it was mold.
And I instantly threw it away.
Because I haven't had sriracha in a long ass time.
Like, like, because like, I never had to use sriracha for a
while.
So, because I recently, I bought Bulldog Sauce.
And I just put that on everything.
like bulldog recently came out with like their own sauces so
like you can actually put bulldog sauce on things so so i
haven't used sriracha in a long ass time but it's just and
so i've just been using the bulldog sauce like the sauce
bottles instead because it's like it gives a bigger kick
because i like spicy food so i've just been putting bulldog
sauce on everything now and um so i never been using my
sriracha so i looked at my sriracha bottle i was like what
the fuck is that I was like, oh, no.
And I realized the lid, the twisty screw, the twisty lid was
like not fully twisted tightly.
So I assumed it was mold.
So yes, yes, I've done that.
Chopped vegetable and left described bits on, no, I don't do
that.
Just throw it out.
Not taking out food or drink sometimes.
Only if like I haven't checked the fridge.
Only if like I've done it for eggs.
I've done it for eggs.
Not, that's only, that's it.
not washed up as you went along when cooking a big meal well
i don't cook big meals for people so i'll skip that i cook
meals for myself only for me
uh kept empty containers and bottles out and all just put in
a trash bag i don't know shoes in different places and had
to hunch through the house to pair them up again no i don't
have a lot of shoes that no more i have like i think i have
like three pairs of shoes one are sandals one are sandals
crocs and sneakers i'm such a bro i'm such a guy sometimes i
learn you know like some guys they wear shoes until they're
like broken down and they're like oh i should get new ones i
literally have you know a shoe for each season crocs sand
like Like, um, sandals and sneakers.
I should get new sneakers.
It's been a while.
They're starting to break down.
Because, like, if it works, it works.
I don't care.
I hated, I hated sneaker shopping with my parents when I
was, like, little.
Because they would, like, make me test all kinds of
sneakers.
And I was just, like, I don't care.
As long as it works, it works.
And then, like, when I shop by myself, I literally pick a
sneaker out.
it and that's the note you don't wear it i was like yeah i
was like but then when i was like with my mom she'd be like
try this and this and this and they're like how do you feel
and then walk around in it oh try this and this and i'm like
i don't i just i don't care like i i just i don't care as
long as they're new and like it works it's fine and like
when i go in i hated sneaker shopping with my mom because it
would take like an hour plus because she would like look at
all the sneakers trying to be like which one is the best one
uh like like in the nikes also she would only buy nikes so
she'd be like looking at the nike shoes and looking which
one is the best nike shoe because she always only bought
nikes i also bought nikes because it's like generational so
you know how like if your parents are like nike people then
you'll only buy nikes so i've never went outside of nikes i
never wore like adida shoes or like puma shoes or anything
i've only worn nike it's like um and then like but then when
i go by choose myself like i literally go in the shop and
like i can't break the chain you know it's like how my
parents have owned like three weiner dogs like we've owned
like two weiner dogs and dad is like my third weiner dog
like we never broke the chain so um anyway so so like uh
when i go to the nike shop by myself to buy shoes i
literally in I see a shoe I like I literally go in it takes
me like less than 15 minutes to buy shoes I go in see the
shoes I like try it on and I wear it out like I would be
like oh you want these shoes and I pay for it and then I
wear it out damn bam that's it takes me less than 15 minutes
it's just so fast it's like bam bam bam I don't care like I
do optimal shopping same with clothes I hated clothes
shopping with my mom because like she would make me try so
many different clothes and then i had to come out i don't
know if this is an asian thing because i don't know like i
don't know if this is just me or like an asian thing um but
she would make me like she would bring me like a whole bunch
of clothes she wanted me to try on and then like and then
like i would have to go into like the changing room i had to
come out of the change room because it's like one person in
a changing room so then like she'd be like god come on show
me and i have to like come out and she's like and then like
now turn around now turn left turn right and that go back it
like it's not just okay it's just a mom thing and then like
she did it all the way till high school so like it was oh
yeah i gotta be like a model for my mom so like she did it
all the way to like high school so like literally when i
went to college i get i just go in see clothes i like see
clothes and pants i like don't try them and then i just buy
and then i go home so like in college i just like i see
paths i was like that's my size and then i just fucking go
home i buy it just go home i don't even try it i fucking
hate changing rooms now i have like changing room trauma
right because i fucking i hated it because it'd be like
because like when like when um my mom was like it's close
time yeah like close because like if it doesn't fit return
it yeah it's if it doesn't fit it doesn't fit so it's not
like like it's not like i can't return it it just saves me
time so um so like and then like yeah and and then like i
just have to like change your room trauma i guess because
it's like every time like i would have to like like I don't
even like at that point like um but and then uh and then
like it basically it was like I it's like pants clothes like
everything and I would go out shred around give her
different angles and then it's one by one I was just like I
can't do this anymore I can't I can't do this anymore if it
doesn't that's why when I shop I'm just like If it doesn't
fit, it doesn't fit.
Like, I don't care.
I'm just so tired.
I see you, Doki.
You are seen.
Fudge shop.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
The nightmare of clothes shopping with parents is also
finding the right suicide constantly because it's always too
loose or too tight.
Speaking of, what's your shoe size don't keep my size i
actually don't remember i don't remember i literally every
time i go like i said barely i barely buy shoes i just like
if i have to buy shoes i go in and just like and they're
like what shoe size are you i take off my shoe i look at it
be like my this is my shoe size i i look at it and be like
oh that's my shoe size and it gets that it that it there it
is i used to buy a lot of shoes back then growing up like in
in high school i was a fan of one particular brand um and i
loved that brand so much i think it was called let me see
shoe brand i'm trying to remember what it's called it was a
it was like a pretty bougie brand though um oh my god i'm
trying to say try to remember shoe brand uh luxury list i'm
um it was a bougie one try to remember what it's called it
wasn't heels it was like it was like more so like sneakers
and like um i i'd hate wearing high he like he anything
related to heels um so like try to remember what it's called
let me check
uh oh st lauren was so good i love um i don't i only own one
pair of St. Lawrence.
It's like my most expensive.
I wish I still have them.
I bought it in New York because like I said, I was like in
a, like I said, I did like model UN and I have one pair of
St. Lawrence shoes.
It was very expensive and I had to have it because it was
really pretty.
It's like my, and I wish I still own it.
I didn't bring it with me when I did the move it was like
whatever it was actually like whenever I'm going to like a a
really nice event or a nice place I would I would bring it I
would like wear those shoes because it was like my like I
actually also own a uh my grandma bought me a uh a Gucci
sneaker as well um I told you guys my grandma was like my my
step grandma so like she would try to buy my love No, I
don't even think it was like Gucci.
I think it was a Chanel sneaker.
Yeah, my grandma, my step-grandma, tried to buy my love
because she was literally like, I think she was like two to
three years older than my oldest uncle.
So I think she bought me a Chanel sneaker when I was in high
school.
I was like really into shoes in high school, but not like
high heels.
It was like sneakers and like flatware because they're like
super comfy too.
I'm trying to remember what it was.
was called like my favorite brand oh my god i love was it
called saboteur for oh my gosh so okay i'm trying i want to
remember what what was my other favorite shoe brand i don't
know if they're still like they're they're still around they
have to be still around though i'm zooming in there's like a
little list but um oh echo i fucking love echo echo was one
of my favorites echo and uh uh salvatore salvatore ferrigamo
they were my favorite shoe brands but like i would just buy
this flats slash sneakers because they were really pretty
but that was like when i was in high school i was like a
shoe collector Well, not collector.
I was just really into their shoes.
No, Echo back then in Asia, in Asia was really popular back
then.
I don't know about now, but Echo, when I was like, when I
used to live in Asia, especially in China, was super
popular.
Yeah.
I don't know about now, but...
They were really pop There were like lots of Yeah They were
all the rage back then And they were really pretty too Like
I like the ones where it had like I don't know They were
really comfy They were really comfy And they were like They
were really pretty But now I don't care Now I have three
pairs of shoes Yeah Now I only have three pairs I don't care
no more because like wearing nice shoes require you to go
outside and i don't go outside as much anymore i oh my god
yeah i think i told you guys i almost i almost i remember i
made an off comment about it um and like i think it was like
during the apex stream but like they invited me to the
streamer awards and like i was like oh if i go in kainito
it's fun right and then like i actually almost went because
i was like i'm not nominated so like there's no cameras on
me but then i found out that the seating list was fucking
public and i was like are you fucking like and then i was
like i'm not going yeah yeah because like people it wasn't
it wasn't public but it wasn't public but like um all the
streamers were showing the seating list and everything
because it was like uh they're like it was online so like
yeah so it was online and then like the streamers like all
the big streamers were literally showing the seating list
and stuff like Oh, these people are sitting there.
These people are sitting there.
So then I was like, okay, I'm not going.
Like, if they see, like, Doki Bird, then, like, people
would, like, try and look at the cameras and stuff.
Be like, where's Doki Bird?
Yeah.
It was a free ticket, like, like, and I could, like, yeah.
So that's why, like, I was just like, bro, that's, like, not
safe for me.
That's, like, whoever's on my table.
with like if they're streaming and there's a lot of people
were doing rl streams too so whoever was on my table they
would have like if i happened to i didn't see the seeing
list because by the time it was finalized i already dropped
out um i already dropped out for it um so that's why like i
didn't go because i'm a very private person so so like
because the seeing list wasn't supposed to be public per se
it's just like other streamers were just showing the seating
list on stream and stuff and it was just highlighting who
was sitting with who yeah so that's why like i i was just
like i wanted i was like i thought it was really fun because
i never been in an event like that before and i thought i
could just go incognito because i was like oh i'm not
nominated for anything so if i'm not nominated for anything
the camera won't be on me like specifically like dodge
donkey bird like you know like you know donkey bird
dominated for this so i was like okay i could i thought it
would be a really cool experience because i was just like oh
like i've never done this like i never gone to i just wanted
to like You know, just wanted to be there just for, like,
the experience.
But then, like, I just felt like, oh, I don't really want...
I was really worried about being on camera.
I was really, like, scared about it.
So I didn't go.
I thought I was, like, I was, like, excited for it, too,
because I just wanted to, like, I wanted to just experience
what it's like to be in one...
Like, just to enjoy these events just for fun.
Not for, like, any...
Like, just for fun and just, like, talk to people, you know,
interact with people and stuff.
like so the but i was just like i just felt scared i was
just like oh like my privacy and stuff i meant you're like
oh you're a streamer you shouldn't you should like but it's
like you know there's an excuse where you're like oh but
you're a streamer like streamers don't have privacy you know
but like but like that's why i wanted to be a vtuber because
i get to enjoy the luxury of my privacy while being able to
stream you know because like, you know, a lot of these other
content creators especially FletchTubers, everything is like
put online, like everything, everything about them.
So to them, they're like to them, it doesn't really matter
to them because their entire lives are practically online.
But I have a huge separation between online, my public
online persona and my private life as well.
So like I have the luxury of having a private life outside
of streaming.
And I don't have to worry about stuff like that by pursuing
VTubing.
And that's why I don't do like IRL appearances or like stuff
like that, because I like having privacy.
I don't know.
I personally like having a life outside, like going to
places without having to like worry about being like stream
sniped or like, that's like one of the things I worry the
most is just like, going outside and being recognized and
stuff like that.
And I don't have to have that fear of that in general,
because I know like I'm very private about myself.
So I can actually go outside and not having to worry about
things like that.
And having to like, like, you see like clips of like big
streamers getting harassed in public and things.
And I don't want to deal with that.
So that's why I like V-Tuning and I very private about like,
you know, separating like flesh like you know there's like
vtubers who do like flesh tubing and also like being a
vtuber um but for me i like the separation because i like
having a i like having a life outside of social media and
content creation and it's nice it's really nice and that's
why i really wanted to go to the streamer event because i
was just like oh i never got a status experience that before
but i realized like if i go there like you know my identity
will be basically exposed to the public so So I was just
like, oh, fuck, okay.
Because I couldn't pretend to be, like, just an Asian girl
here.
Just like, yeah.
So it's just like, you know, just be like this random plus
one Asian girl.
But I can't because the seating arrangement was out.
Like, yeah.
Face masks doesn't, I don't think like, I don't, I know like
someone will just put a face mask.
But it doesn't really matter because your top part.
You get the eyes, too.
It's like the eyes and stuff.
I don't think, like, face mask works as well as you guys
think.
Because the eyes are the most recognizable part of a person.
I guess you can wear glasses, but then you're like, that's a
V-tuber.
Okay, but then, like, the thing is, when you wear face mask
and glasses, everyone was like, that's the V-tuber.
So it's also that, too.
Like, I remember watching the streamer once, I was like, I
could tell which one's the V-Tuber.
Because they're the ones that are wearing the face mask and
the sunglasses.
So you're like, that's the V-Tuber over there.
It's trying to hide their identity.
So I don't want to deal with that, too.
Yeah.
Because no one else is wearing it.
Did you see the V-Tuber?
Did you see it?
That's why when I went to China for the Marvel Rivals Land,
I was just chilling because I was like an Asian in the sea
of Asians.
I was just like, I didn't even wear a face mask or anything.
I was just like, I was just like, I mean, I had to wear face
masks later on because I started to get a little sick.
I started getting sick, so I had to wear a face mask later
on.
But like, it was really hiding in like plain sight when I
was like in China.
yeah when i was like in china for the marvel rivals land and
then there was like other streamers there and everything and
then like they didn't know i was there and i was there
because like they just thought i was this part of the staff
team when i was hanging out with the staff
yeah they just thought i was like part of the staff team
because i was speaking in chinese too like to them like when
i was talking to the staff during the marvel rivals rivals
land i was instead of english no when you speak in chinese
like when you speak in different languages your tone is
different in general i don't know for anyone else who are
who know more than one language but like when you have when
you speak a different language um you you're the way you
speak and your tone changes as well because i know when i
speak in chinese my tone gets deeper
next see thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
Doki Berky-Gi-Gi-Gi with the anime face mask.
They'll know it's you, but they won't know what you're
looking like.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Yeah, I sound really different when I speak in Chinese.
Alright, let's go back to the quiz.
Oh my god, three hours has passed, bro.
Buzzfeed.
Buzzfeed's still.
No matter how many years passed, Buzzfeed will still suck
your soul dry.
we haven't even finished this quiz yet all right now i watch
those well i went okay we found all odd shoes left toilet
paper rolls and a pile on the toilet roll holder and
self-stroke okay i have done that i haven't not on the
toilet roll holder though not that though but um what the
fuck the toilet okay i would not even use like because like
i just i have done that Because I was just like, I'll clean
it up later.
I'll clean.
Why is that gross?
It's just an empty toilet roll.
But I wouldn't leave it on the toilet roll holder.
I'll put it on the sink.
Like the tape.
The sink tape.
Because it's also next to me too.
Okay, I'll close the lid on the toothpaste.
I don't know how that's gross, guys.
How is that gross?
It's just convoid.
I don't have a trash can next to me.
I don't have a trash can in the bathroom.
just lazy exactly it's not gross it's just lazy it's not
gross it's just lazy that's right it can't be gross okay as
a woman like what else can i do as a woman it's just the way
of life as a I have a lot of hair It's just It's just a way
of life I
I just I do Yeah I
don't I don't let it clog up I don't let this happen
Next thing this super chat thing thank you i just don't have
a trash can next to my bathroom okay i just don't have it
okay uh
okay i don't leave it lying around i put it in the in the
shopping bag drawer so i don't check that you know you know
the shopping bag drawer it's just like i'll use it one day
and then you never use it like what the fuck is a hob i
don't know what this is
misplaced the remote i don't have a tv so that can't happen
to me yes the class yes shove it in there okay that has
happened to me that has happened to me wait yes wait yes
sometimes sometimes it slips between my bed
said that I just said I'm lazy yes um have to shove
everything you own okay no I don't do that I literally do
like if someone's coming over to visit I I actually spend
like a day or two cleaning everything up I I don't shove
things up I actually go like deep clean mode Before, I was
very, very, very depressed.
Been told off of work for having a messy desk.
Cat, cat, do that when I'm the CEO.
I'm my own boss.
Okay, none of these matter to me because I'm my own boss.
I don't.
That's right.
Cat, tell myself off.
Hover, rude.
Wait, hoovered around things?
I don't know what that means.
Not bothered to hoover, I won't pick a large, noticeable
item.
What the fuck is a hoover?
Are these the mini vacuums?
Is that what it is?
Treated a table like a shelf?
Oh!
Oh, it's vacuumed.
No, I've vacuumed.
No, I don't.
don't do that.
I think, I'm sorry, for anyone that eats in bed, you don't
eat where you sleep.
I, I think that's pretty gross.
I would eat where I work.
I would eat at the table, but I would not, it's also like
not convenient at all.
Like, it's like, cause I need a table, you know?
So it's like, it's like, it's like, where do I put my food,
you know?
Yeah.
Don't eat where you sleep.
I just I need, like, a table to put my food down.
Treat a table like a shelf.
I mean, yeah, I put stuff around my table.
Okay, no.
No.
Have your mates sigh at you.
Okay, yeah, and a discord call, yeah.
I feel like my cleaner has sighed at me.
I mean...
Yes, my mom has.
Yes.
all right you're a bit oh a bit a bit yeah you're a bit of a
fucking mess you probably aren't guilty of lingering i took
it that's a little wrong but you're also not the type to do
it straight away out of it being tidy is something you have
you accept but dirty on the hand oh guys see i'm i'm just a
little bit of a fucking mess guys just a little bit
Just a little bit, guys.
Only a teensy-weezy.
See, guys, I'm not a mess.
Which my little...
I know, like, I think it was...
Was it Orca?
I was spamming this.
Which my little...
I'll do this.
Which my little pony character are you?
Need some rat rainbow foods to find out.
Alright.
What am I?
Red.
I...
Tom yum soup is so fucking good.
I'm gonna choose Tom yum.
I fucking love Tom yum soup orange.
Oh, I fucking love salmon.
Fuck.
Give me, I like, okay, well, I was sick.
Literally, I had salmon two days in a row because salmon is
really good for your, like, for your body when you're sick.
So I literally was eating salmon three days in a row.
I even ate salmon today, but I ate, like, sushi.
Like, I Googled, is sushi okay for you?
And then Google said, no, because raw fish is not good for
you when you're sick but i was like i'm not gonna listen to
google i i'm gonna choose to ignore that because it's still
salmon it's i was like i choose to ignore when it doesn't
fit when it doesn't fit my my plans
ravioli because i love pasta i decided mangoes are ravioli
but i love ravioli more Where it doesn't fit my agenda, I
choose to ignore.
No, I wasn't the AI.
I was like, I don't, I don't look at AI.
I always like double check from below.
But even they were like, even they were like, don't do it.
And I was like, I choose, if it doesn't fit my agenda, then
it doesn't exist.
Pesto pasta.
Well, I'm such a- Rainbow Dash!
Okay, that- okay, that's actually perfect.
I'm definitely Rainbow Dash.
Oh my- I love- I'm such a child.
are bubble plum and cotton candy yeah rainbow dash I you
know like the voice actors um it's it's like oh it's like
kpop demon hunters but the sick usually the singers for my
little pony aren't even the actual voice actors it's like
someone else like I don't like the sunset shimmer voice
actress it's actually the singing voice of Twilight Sparkle
because what's her name I forgot the The girl who does
Twilight Sparkle's voice acting, she doesn't sing.
But a lot, yeah, a lot of the voice actors by The Pony don't
sing their own songs.
That's usually how it goes, because sometimes it's hard to
sing in those voices.
It's like K-pop Demon Hunters.
I feel so bad for the...
Yeah, Taka Straw.
I feel so bad for the main voice actor.
Um...
I feel so bad for the main voice actors for K-pop Demon
Hunters.
hunters because like because like everyone's talking about
the the singers of kpop demon hunters because like you know
like it's like the singers of kpop demon hunters are
different from the actual voices from the like they're both
i mean from the voice actors who voiced the characters from
kpop demon hunters and it's like but like the only people
the singers are the only ones getting publicities and all
the interviews all the interviews all the performances and
everything You rarely ever see, like, the voice actors for
K-pop Demon Hunters doing interviews or publicity stuff.
Yeah.
I feel so bad for them.
Because it's literally, like, the only time they were
like...
I think the only time they were there was for the Critics'
Choice Awards.
Yeah.
I mean, it makes sense because, you know, the songs are the
main attractions.
But I just feel bad for them.
Because, like...
Because they were also, they're also, like, well-known.
like there are also well-known actors actresses too it's
just rough because like literally all the interviews every
single interview for kpop demon hunters are literally the
singers and not the voice actors even though the voice
actors also helped build the characters for them
all right i'm sorry about hotel anyone over 25 years old is
gonna pass this 2025 pop culture quiz
all right here if you're over 22 and get at least 15 out of
20 on this cartoon silhouette quiz there's no way there's no
way this is that hard i am a god i keep cursed but i gotta
double shake it this is a fucking curse that is the first
like what do people under 22 not know garfield like what the
fuck okay double check this whatever type okay like who
could that who Who's that Pokemon?
There you go.
Garfield.
There's no way.
Okay.
Homer Simpsons.
Oh my god.
Velma.
Fred Flintstone.
Okay.
Optimus Prime.
Oh, Sailor Moon.
Okay, there's no way.
Excellent taste and ice cream flavors.
Lolly, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, Tiana.
Uh, Knuckles.
I just love cartoons and animation in general.
Ursula.
Uh, Moana.
This is so easy.
Bugs of bunny.
Tweety.
Oh, I love Tweety Bird.
Bro, I'm speedrunning this.
Kirby, Charizard,
Pop-Eyes.
Oh.
I can't type right now.
What?
Oh, is it Pop-Eyes?
Pop-Eyes?
Oh, it's Pop-Eyes.
Pepper.
Pop-Eyes.
The Sailor Man.
Percy.
Wait, wait.
Mr. Krabs.
I thought it was like, because I'm like, Papa is the Sailor
Man.
Oh, Yu-Gi-Oh.
Wait.
Is that how you spell Yu-Gi-Oh?
Yu-Gi-Oh.
Oh.
Oh, Yu-Gi-Oh.
Yu-Gi-Moto.
I was like, Yu-Gi-Oh.
Oh, his name is Yu-Gi.
Oh, Smurfette.
I scored better than 100%.
How many people took this quiz?
I'm the only one that got everything.
I think I'm, like, the only person that took this quiz.
Oh, my God.
There's no comments.
I might be the only one that took this quiz, guys.
I think I'm nearly one person.
John, you here.
oh wait travel around wait let's look at trending i feel
like the latest quizzes will have like no one answering hall
of fame oh wait this is the one i just took oh wait if you
can add wait what's your tech where is the trending quizzes
oh it is the trending which one is up again if you score uh
you're officially a certified
all right travel okay we'll see if they can pick out dad
there's 42 comments the bread quiz we'll do the bread quiz
after okay pick a place to visit all right let's see if they
guess my dog correctly i've actually been here i've been
here this is cool i don't know being next to a river is is
so i hate the beach and being next to a river fucking sucks
because it's always so smelly.
Uh...
I'll go to the market.
This is fun.
This place is fun.
Pick a place to visit.
Why the fuck would I go to a cemetery?
Oh my god, that's sad.
I'm sorry.
I'm going to do the Santa Monica Pier because there's stuff
to do there.
What the fuck?
I don't want to go...
I don't want to go to the fucking cemetery.
That's sad.
If I'm fucking going or if I'm traveling, what the fuck?
I'll go have fun.
I don't care about, I honestly, I don't care about nature.
I'm just here for, like, fun experience.
I think this is just, I guess this, oh, is this the Las
Vegas strip?
Because it's, like, in Nevada.
I don't know.
I don't care about gambling.
Because I know it'd be, well, the thing is, I've never
actually gambled before in real life, like, casinos or
whatever.
Because I was never of, like, legal age for it.
So I feel like I have very addicting personality and I feel
like if I do gamble, it's over for me So so I don't want to
go there Oh, Universal Studios I don't want to go to
Universal Studios If they give up five gift dishes, they can
thank you
Yeah, I heard like people are like not going to Las Vegas
anymore It's just way too expensive pick a place to visit I
don't know any of these What the fuck are any of these?
I'll go to a museum This looks nice I don't know what these
are I assume this is like Las Vegas like hotel I'll do that
I know that's like I know that's from Hangover I remember
that I remember this place from Hangover The movie But I
assume like Uh It's like a casino, right?
The only thing I want to go to in Nevada is the...
Is that shop...
Is that grocery store?
The trippy grocery store that's in Las Vegas.
That's the only place I want to go in Nevada.
Oh, Museum of Pop Culture.
Oh, Fifth Avenue, New York City.
New York is always fun.
When you're like a tourist, not like living there, I feel
like.
I feel like New York is very expensive Yeah, Omega Mart I
want to go to Omega Mart I mean, Museum of Pop Culture
Sounds really fun I don't know what it is But like, I love
Broadway High Roller High Roller, Nevada More Casino Palace
of Fine Arts It's a palace.
I'll go here.
This doesn't look very fun.
I look at this and it looks sad.
This place, it looks sad.
Oh, I've...
Have I been there?
I feel like I've seen this.
I've seen this before.
I don't know if I've been there.
Oh!
This is nice.
This is a nice place.
Oh, is this NASA?
I don't know.
go to nasa wait it's not called nasa anymore right i don't
remember how did i go there seven magic mountains falling
water i'm kind of glad to have you online through my hell
network thank you super chat brady thank you
it's so oh nasa still exists okay they keep changing so many
names so i'm I can't keep track of anymore.
I can't keep track of all the name changes.
Um, I don't know.
I like this because it's inside.
And I assume it has air conditioning.
I got a hamster.
It's not even a dog.
What the fuck?
It's not a hamster.
You're a quirky and friendly.
And then the hamster again.
Another hamster?
Do you?
Okay, I guess I'm a hamster.
I don't want to own a hamster.
These guys are...
They're like...
Like, they will...
They, like, you know...
They eat their babies and shit.
I'm, like, worried about that.
And they really...
If you don't...
If you're not careful, they're going to make a lot of
babies, too.
They're going to make a lot of babies if you're not careful.
I'm not going to do the transformer one because I will
purposely pick to be a Decepticon because I fucking hate the
Autobots.
I think the Decepticons are cooler.
And I would, like, subconsciously pick, um, pick, like, uh,
pick for, like, a Decepticon pick.
All right, we'll do one more.
All right, I'm going to see what we can do.
All right, give me a sec.
All right.
What is your purity?
How basic are you?
Your basic.
Okay, we got...
All right, give me...
We'll take this.
How basic am I, guys?
Take me to be able to check all...
Okay, I don't think I'm basic.
You love you.
You own a pair.
I actually don't.
What the fuck is Snorface?
Can't get enough of the...
You own socks for your favorite workout.
You have a yoga yoga.
You love...
I hate candles.
Okay, no, I'm definitely not basic.
I have...
Wait, is basic like...
Oh my god, basic is the old normie.
I just realized that.
Oh my god.
This is like, we call, it's like troll, it's like rage bait
is now, you trolling is now rage bait.
And basic is like normie now.
I'm not, I'm not normie no more.
I just don't like candles.
I think it's like, I just, like, I don't, I don't need
candles and I don't care for it.
you follow astrology you have an astrological sign tattoo
you blame things on mercury being in retrograde you've done
this but i have no idea what mercury in retrograde means you
love brunch you love instagramming brunch you love tweeting
bro brunch is fire though you have a brunch crew it's just
like this is Mostly about brunch.
You protested.
So you thought New York was going to take away bottomless
brunches.
You say marks instead of margaritas.
You abbreviate.
Okay, that's me.
You own the sex and I've never watched sex in the city.
I know it's a good show, but I've never watched it.
I watched Desperate Housewives.
That was a good show.
But how much do you love brunch, don't you?
You have a spin instructor that everyone you've taken a
healer.
off after a long light of party got into heat and disgust or
something i had no idea but you soberly got into it over
something yes actually i've done both actually um you love
vodka sodas because of a lack of calories linda is your
lifeblood you love diet coke you call diet coke dc you love
taylor's okay i actually low-key not current taylor so if
she she's not sad anymore so her songs aren't as I know it's
fucked up to say, but you have to admit, like, her older
songs, I actually really enjoy her older songs when she
always sing about, like, breakups and stuff, because they're
actually, like, they're, like, I don't know, I don't
remember the lyrics, but, like, those, they're, like, pretty
good.
yeah shake it off shake it off that song was always stuck in
my head yeah and then she got like happy about her love life
and then her song no longer was that good her her country
song was good too i don't remember what the lyrics of 22.
i'm on a 22.
you're pretty sure molly cyrus invented twerking okay that's
that's basic
Okay, you've actually been excited about skinny marks.
You've actually been excited.
You've been on the juice cleanse.
You claim you love to it.
You cried, I need to.
This quiz has been done three million times.
Wait, how many times?
This quiz has been done like three million times or some
shit, right?
Yeah, three million times.
Bro, how many people are basic?
Oh my god.
It's a skinny margarita.
I assume it has low alcohol.
How about 3 million basic bitches?
People really wanted to know if they're basic.
You call yourself fat to bond with your friends.
You bought something just because it was a designer.
Yes.
You bought a fake designer.
a fake designer you've gotten to coachella you've gone to
coachella multiple times you started to coach your chella
i've been coachella rochella okay oh a headband at coachella
i've worn headbands before but not coachella oh like native
american headbands are like oh wait never mind i thought
they meant like hair like you know like the hair bands for a
headband i didn't realize they meant like native american
headband i thought i thought they meant like like you know
like like hair bands type shit you don't see that as
offensive you plan your okay this is oh you subscribe to
goop oh my god not guinif patro's goop she made a candle
that's scented for like the vagina she made a vagina scented
candle you have an opinion on guinif i do
but not the positive type of not the positive type of fuck
of of Gwyneth though yeah like she's like she had her own
like her own cult at one point it's it's her it's her corpo
Goup is Gwyneth Paltrow's company where like it's she
preaches about like women's health and stuff and one of them
was like and then like she was selling like health health
items geared towards women and one of them was like candles
that were scented like a vagina and i was just like bro
i'm so weird i am
what the who's nicholas sparks like it's what's what's the
jade i actually don't remember the jade egg i just remember
the candle because i thought that was weird i don't know who
nicholas spark is because that requires me to read
oh the notebook why do you hate love i told you i don't
watch like rom-coms or romantic movies I just find them
boring.
I think romance movies are boring to me I I mean I like
rom-coms with the ones I did watch because they're funny
like one from comedy actors But like I don't like romance
movies because I just find it way too boring Oh my god, it's
like that Twitter Twitter post where this girl posted a
tweet about her She's like guys here are all the books I
fucking read like she was she was like flexing it and then
people were like Bro, all those books are boring.
That was so funny.
Like, people all...
They were, like, analyzed their titles.
And it was, like, literally, like, hardcore, like, sex
books.
Like, like, you know, sex stories.
Like, smut.
It was, like, smut stories.
Smut books.
And I was like, bro, look.
I keep that in the fan fictions.
I don't need no books for that shit I got fanfics for that I
don't need a build up to Control F
You love the You watch, I've never watched Love, actually
You love getting drunk and watching What the fuck, you love
white wine I hate wine It's just so bitter
whether it's term you use with gusto you consider yourself a
daddy's girl you love pumpkin okay pumpkin spice is actually
really good though i will i am a daddy's girl i am i am i
like my dad more you bought a book because it was one of
oprah's picks you watch the bachelor you know who the fuck
as Juan Pablo you love Rita or you own rainbow sandals you
felt personally victimized by Justin Bieber okay you know
who you're okay I do actually you have a tattoo you're such
a cute you have such a cute little tattoo behind your ear on
the back of your head you said chicks before
dicks and secretly not bent it.
I always just threw bros before hoes.
Your nails have had nail art on them.
You love a good use love.
Okay, Froyo is fucking fired though.
Those like, those places that do like, I haven't had Froyo.
I haven't had, uh, did you mean it?
I haven't had Froyo in a long ass time but when you do froyo
it's frozen yogurt um because like frozen froyo does not
taste like yogurt and it's that it just tastes like ice
cream and you do like pick your toppings too and then like
like uh you can pick your toppings for froyo as well it's
like nice um it was a fad back then but it was really good i
like froyo i didn't get i didn't get a lot but when i can i
can it's pretty good it's like apparently it's like
healthier than regular ice cream um no it depends on I went
to there was a fro yo place that I went to that was like it
does not taste like yogurt and it tastes more like ice cream
you use literally very yeah and it sounds like literally I
don't know I can't even yeah I can't even with you right now
it's you have lost a single shoe at a party when you get
drunk you find yourself say oh my god I love you you say oh
my he's so Like, bro, I can't use that reference.
I don't know sex in the city.
I...
You never admit to farting.
You told people you've never farted.
Yeah, guys, I've never farted before.
Same here.
You love Starbucks.
Your Starbucks person knows your order.
You got a skinny version of a Starbucks drinks.
You love wearing leggings.
You've been in a sexy version of Starbucks.
something for Halloween you love keeping up a Kardashian you
actually keep up with them oh my god people actually keep up
with the Kardashians on Vogue cover you've owned jean shorts
you made your own jean shirt you're wondering why I was not
calling them shorts you love the royal family I love Queen
Elizabeth the second you followed what you bought something
Kate Middleton war you rate upset okay I actually did I
actually watched the whirlwind because I was like At that
time, when it happened, I was actually curious.
I didn't care about the baby, though.
The royal wedding was, I just wanted to watch it.
Because it was, like, the first time I've ever seen a royal
wedding.
You only, you love talking about loving Chipotle.
You call it Chipotle.
You want Chipotle right now.
You call someone a basic bitch.
Okay, yeah.
You're really concerned with being, I show my results.
All right.
You're not basic at all.
I'm six, I'm not even...
50%.
You're not basic at all.
You may like a few, thank God, basic things because you're
human, but you're also down and out basic.
Nope.
Unless of course you don't like any of things because
everyone likes them because that's pretty basic too.
See?
See guys?
I'm not basic, guys.
Just as we thought.
Look at that.
Guys, I'm not basic.
much do you hate people okay wait wait let's look at i
actually wanted to see what all right what biblical heroin
are you choose an angel wait okay guys let's see what
biblical okay oh it's no longer available never mind we
don't know which biblical heroin are you no
all right What else do they have?
Build a perfect boyfriend and we'll reveal the deep truth
about you.
I wonder why.
Yeah, I wonder why.
But there was some fucked up quizzes they have.
Yeah, I don't want to mention it.
But it was like a really, it was a really funny one.
because it's pretty messed up.
It was like in the, it was like, I'll Google like top
funniest BuzzFeed quizzes.
And like, it was like, and then like that was one of the
choices.
I would say like, and I looked at the quiz and it was like,
and okay, the questions were, some of the questions there
was pretty funny, but like I couldn't do it on stream.
I don't think I can.
Which Disney villain are you?
Okay, I'll do that one.
Funny how it was in the Reddit thread for funniest BuzzFeed
quizzes.
And I looked it because it was like, it was in the category
of like, it was listed within like, which Illuminati member
are you?
But like, there was another top, there was another quiz that
the same person gave.
I was like, it was okay, I'll say it was like, what's what,
like the two, they gave three choices.
potato.
The other one was, which Illuminati member are you?
I wanted to do that one, but then I looked at it, and then
it was God.
And then there was the third quiz.
And that was the quiz where I looked, I clicked on it, and
then I looked at the questions, and like the first question
was fucking so funny.
And then I was like, I cannot do this quiz.
So that might give you a hint.
Yeah, that's the hint.
Gave you the biggest hint.
This person listed three quizzes.
They listed three quizzes.
One was, what is your inner potato?
The second one was, what, okay, the third, second one was
that other quiz.
The third one was, what is your, what is your inner, like,
what Illuminati member are you?
You found, yeah, I don't.
Look at the quiz questions.
It's so fucking funny, but I can't do.
No, it's not the inner, I didn't list the third, this third
quiz.
All right, what?
What's your greatest quality?
Being manipulative, being sinister, being vain.
Okay, we're not doing this quiz.
get this dude straight to the core yeah someone in chat
someone in chat like um listed the quiz now you can sell why
i can't do that quiz on stream but the questions are so the
first question was crazy and i was just like oh my god
All of the bo-bo-bub, so she skipped it.
Very...
Can you spot the fuck, boy?
Yeah, I love must-be quizzes.
They're so fucking stupid.
I love it.
Would you consider yourself a temper?
That's your answer.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
When she was present, are you?
Should we know the name of your next life?
or based on the food you ordered from McDonald's.
Which country do you actually belong in?
Bro, I feel like you can put that on hell.
I don't think they're going to put me in Canada.
Do you actually...
Okay, yeah, let's do it.
Do I actually have terrible food opinions?
Alright, mayonnaise, mayo.
Oh my god.
Wait, that's not an opinion.
It's biased as hell.
No.
Okay.
Yeah, fuck Marmite fruit.
Yeah, white chocolate.
Yeah!
This quiz sucks.
Pick it up.
Exactly.
Beer or wine?
I'll pick wine.
I hate beer more.
Rice or noodles.
Oh, that's so hard.
I love Bulldog noodles, though.
And I love rice.
I'm going to say noodles.
What?
This is a period.
This is controversial.
Yes.
Hell no.
Sinatra's good.
That's shit.
Okay, I don't care That both of them are good I hate peanut
butter.
I didn't grow up with peanut butter So like I don't care.
I have no opinion.
So she's crunchy Oh Ew What Tea or cop tea Yeah Salsa or
sour cream I like salsa more Liquorish terrible Chocolate
vanilla Pizza pasta What pasta there's so many varieties
this cuisine is invalid nay yeah uh oh that's hard I like
both I'll do hot dogs what they're both bread with me inside
the end day but hamburgers have a certain genus sequa that's
not true hot dogs I like hot dogs more than hamburgers onion
rings what oh blue cheese delight okay not too bad aren't
great okay This is biased as hell.
Yeah, this quiz is fucking biased, bro.
My, your food opinion sucks.
Wait, what Disney princess am I?
Okay, well, I end it with this one.
I'm sorry.
I keep picking quizzes.
Yeah, that one.
All right, let's see.
Where am I?
What is your favorite Disney movie?
Who the fuck would pick Black Cauldron?
Lion King.
I think Lion King's the best.
Oh, the love, uh, her.
Oh, wait, no.
Is this herbie unleashed?
Okay, if this was the sequel from Lindsay low hand and
that's good too um lion king is my favorite um your enemies
are probably envious of your what is it my passion my
determination oh that's hard i think my determination where
are you or yeah determination where are you most scared of
losing my job is all like
I think war is more Yeah, I'll say war No, guys, I think war
is Scarier than corporations and losing My job, I think I
don't want to be in war here That's what you look For in a
soulmate I just wanted them to be kind To me
And funny And like I'm not a gold taker but it would be nice
to know that I'm not funding someone else's life you know I
don't I don't want to be a sugar mama I but I do want them
to be kind yeah
okay um I think nice being nice would be nice
to talk to a Phoenix bluebird of the animals can't talk I
would say that the animals can't talk what do you like to do
yeah you're more of the sugar Nexi thank you the super chat
thank you thank you what do you like to do with your time
off.
I'm always playing video games.
I'm always working.
What is the secret to true love?
Chemistry, I feel.
I mean, that's everything, to be fair.
I feel like it doesn't matter.
It's always just chemistry.
Yeah.
I say chemistry.
What would you like to have?
I don't...
Ah, Sue is cool.
Food.
I don't know.
I feel like...
What if they pick a bad movie?
You know?
I think you gotta want to fucking pick a bad movie.
Because you don't know what they're...
into and you don't know what they don't know what i'm into
too i would say a restaurant food is the way to the heart
yeah food or like yeah food fuck these pick a singer riley
cyrus what will smith say more than whip your hair back and
forth beyond okay bruno mars i fucking love bruno mars songs
i think that he had like i've listened to more
Dangers.
Bro, I feel like a mansion is too much.
I think, like, living in a mansion ain't it.
Because it's, like, scary, you know.
It's, like, so empty and everything.
Like, you know, monsters can, like, pop up anywhere, you
know, in a mansion.
I don't, I rather prefer an apartment.
achieving my dreams i'm tiana tiana yeah too many rooms for
nothing yeah i like apartments more i think like the bigger
the house the less like i don't know i feel like it's just
not as comfy i just like having everything like there yeah
all the scooby-doo mysteries happen in mansion guys i ain't
here for the scooby-doo mysteries oh wait i want to see
equal having good friends having a job finding and not sure
i think achieving my dreams you're commonly upset clear
goals that you have intent to reach no matter the obstacle
people consider you to be yeah i'm tiana i was like what's
your song uh almost there you're if you uh do you ever feel
like a plastic bag drifting through the wind early night
manana all right wait let me look up through one more quiz
I'm sorry I can't I can't stop taking quizzes this is how
they get you guys this is guys how about one more one more
quiz
all right can you pick the guy with the 5 million people
holy guys from 5 million people took this quiz it's crazy
it's actually crazy
you can't know i'm not gonna fucking take that quiz you guys
can take that quiz
all right how white are you As a non-white person, how white
am I?
How...
Do it for the bros.
How privileged are you?
Banana.
I call myself a banana.
Oh, we did that one earlier.
That was with like 48 million and I got Colorado.
out.
What are your quizzes?
Just answer and we'll give you an... I don't know.
What should we end it with?
What dog am I?
What the fuck?
How popular your Hogwarts house opinions of this RuPaul's
Drag Race Queen?
That's so funny.
Where's the connection?
Oh wait, we gotta this one i forgot about this which danny
davido character you're most like based on these seven
questions okay guys guys i gotta know which danny davido
character am i all right pick a career i want to be an
entrepreneur i choose a disney character like the beast like
who the fuck is governor red i would oh the oh wait Mad
Hatter He seems fun Choose a celebrity I don't want Steve's
jobs He got cancer and died That's way too sad You know
what?
Bill Murray is such a fucking vibe He does whatever fuck he
wants According to tests I'm the penguin
Bro this guy Okay, you can't say he was smart and rich.
This guy, he got the cancer diagnosis, and then he was like,
I'm not going to trust real science.
I'm going to stick things up my ass.
Like, I do not want to be Steve Jobs.
He literally could have got his cancer cured.
Yeah.
He's like, I'm going to go with the, I'm going to go with
the, what are they called?
What are those, what are those medications?
Like the non-science ways of fucking medications.
Yeah, he got he caught it super early and he's like, I'm not
gonna do like that holistic He did holistic treatments for
it and one of them was sticking shit up his ass And then it
like progressed and then when it progressed too late, he's
like, okay, I'll trust science now And then it was too late
and then he died like I'm sorry, but like this guy was not
smart He had all the money in the world and he just decided
to stick things up his ass Yeah, it is one of the most
treatable cancers
It was a choice Yeah
That's how it goes Choose a Wario
Wait actually King DDD though Oh my god Is that a Wario or
King DDD?
Fuck I love King DDD in the Kirby show Okay I went with
Wario first though Pick a Marvel character Bro I hate all of
it Okay he's funny okay we're not picking rocket i was like
oh but i loved him in the show in the curvy show curvy curvy
curvy curvy curvy curvy but uh my grandmaster he was pretty
funny pick a dc character lex looser yeah i like jeff globel
him he just plays himself he literally an act and i think
that's funny she was a tv show okay all community but i got
what dude oh wait oh my god yeah wait he was in i didn't
know he was in that movie it wasn't space jam i didn't
realize he was the guy from space jam you're a ruthless oh
my welcome to the space jam Yes, I didn't realize Daddy
DeVito was the main villain in Space Jam.
Come on, Slap.
Oh, my God, I want to sing Space Jam.
You're a ruthless, business alien who will stop at nothing
to keep us amusing apart.
Yay!
Even if he's facing the Looney Tunes and Michael Jordan in a
basketball game to determine whether or not they become your
slaves.
Yay!
I'm a ruthless businesswoman.
Come on, Slap.
And welcome to the Jam.
Let's go.
let's let you go all right that was fun i'll do more of us
for your quizzes in the future i think there were so there
were so many that um it's just business welcome yes it's
dokeylon i gotta do everything to keep dokeylon afloat um
but it was really fun i hope you guys enjoyed um hang out
with me just taking random quizzes i love to do more quizzes
in the future um and i had um it was fucking wild some of
those quizzes are but i hope the dragon ones had fun with
the quiz i did not mention uh dokey is the swag hack uh the
swag hammer of dokey lodge peter thank you the super chat
thank you thank you time passed by so fast i did not even
realize four hours passed by i nearly got sucked into the
buzzfeed of quizzes
Like, it was just honestly, it was just really fun just
taking random quizzes with you guys.
Hey, I'm going to head off now.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed because you deserve
it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.